Christophe Bruet, bonsoir.
Bonsoir à vous.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct avant de vous présenter
succintement précaution oratoire. Pas de
diffamation, pas de dénigrement, pas de
nom et on expliquera pourquoi après.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Très bien. Donc
Christophe Brusset, je suis ingénieur
agroalimentaire.
J'ai aussi une formation en achat, un 3è
cycle en achat et puis un MBA que j'ai
fait un peu par la suite. J'ai commencé
ma carrière dans l'agroalimentaire, donc
en tant qu'ingénieur projet dans
l'alimentation animale et ensuite
j'étais acheteur puis responsable achat,
directeur des achats dans différentes
entreprises, des PME au début et puis
des multinationales par la suite. Euh
donc j'ai une expérience assez longue
puisque j'ai commencé ma carrière en
1993.
Euh et j'ai fait beaucoup d'import. Donc
j'ai eu la chance de voyager beaucoup
hein puisque j'ai j'ai fait énormément
de déplacements dans beaucoup de pays
mais beaucoup en Asie avec beaucoup de
d'achat et de contact en Chine depuis
toutes ces années. Euh j'ai eu aussi la
chance de travailler à l'étranger, de
vivre à l'étranger quelques années, donc
9 ans à Singapour, 2 ans maintenant en
Autriche. Euh et je crois avoir une
assez bonne connaissance de
l'agroalimentaire. Donc c'est mon
expertise. Depuis 2015, j'écris des
livres pour parler de l'agroalimentaire
et de de pointer du doigt certains
problèmes que j'aimerais voir résolus.
euh notamment la malbouffe et tous les
problèmes de santé puisque
malheureusement aujourd'hui la malbouffe
est la première cause de mortalité au
monde he c'est c'est l'OMS qui le dit
avec un décès sur 5 qui est dû à la
malbouffe donc au diabète maladie nche
maladie différent maladies
cardio-vasculair maladie chronique enfin
voilà donc c'est un un vrai désastre et
malheureusement les pouvoirs publics et
les industriels réagissent avec molesse
et et malheureusement on n'est pas
encore au pique de l'épidémie.
On vous avait reçu en 2019 euh
pour parler déjà de tout ça, comment
l'industrie agroalimentaire
s'arrangeait ou on va dire maximisait.
Je je conseille d'ailleurs de regarder
optimiser
et là vous avez commis un un dernier
livre qui s'appelle la malbouffe
contreattaque.
Oui.
Alors avant de rentrer dans le détail de
la contre-attaque, aujourd'hui on va
parler malbouffe, on va parler bio, on
va parler sécurité alimentaire
et on va parler on va rentrer dans tout
tout plein de détails. On va pomper
votre expérience professionnelle, puis
dans votre dans vos connaissances. On
parle de la malbouffe.
Bah, je suis là pour ça. Allons-y.
Allons-y.
C'est quoi la malbouffe en fait ?
Alors, la malbouffe, c'est un concept
qui a évolué, c'est-à-dire que ça date
des années, on va dire, pour vraiment
remonter à l'origine des années 40 aux
États-Unis où on a parlé de junk food.
Donc, c'est vraiment le terme est là.
euh en fait pour parler de nourriture
qui rendait malade, c'est-à-dire les
Américains ont constaté que si on
consommait trop de produits gras et
sucré essentiellement voir salé par la
suite, on était malade, on était obèse,
on était malade. Euh en France, c'est le
couple de Ren qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle malbouffe justement. Donc
c'est une contraction de malnutrition et
de grande bouffe euh pour décrire cette
nourriture qui rendait malade. Donc
c'est un livre qui a été écrit si je me
trompe pas dans les années 1976
et qui a vraiment pas du tout perdu de
sa pertinence. Et euh et donc au début,
on parlait de de nourriture
déséquilibrée et le concept a un petit
peu évolué aujourd'hui puisque on parle
de malbouffe pour décrire toute la
nourriture qui nous rend malade. Donc on
a aussi inclu la nourriture qui contient
des des polluants, des pesticides, des
additifs, des des choses toxiques. Et
aujourd'hui, avec la conscience
environnementale et la conscience
éthique, on inclut aussi dans la
malbouffe tout ce qui est produit de
manière
anormale et qui qui dégrade
l'environnement.
C'est la malbouffe qui rend malade mais
c'est un peu comme tout. Si je consomme
de tout avec excès, non, je vais être
malade pas, je me fais l'avocat du
diable direct. Oui, mais c'est c'est
comme la vie, au final, on en meurt.
Mais euh
disons que aujourd'hui, on est dans une
situation où l'espérance de vie ne
progresse plus. Par contre, les années
de de de les dernières années de vie
sont de plus en plus en mauvaise santé.
C'estàd qu'on a un développement énorme
de maladies chroniques, typiquement le
diabète de type 2
à la charge de l'État, la fin de vie.
C'est ça.
La charge de la collectivité.
L'État, c'est nous comme dirait pour
pour parodier le 14. Enfin, l'État c'est
nous ou
Mélenchon, c'est pas lui qui avait dit
quelque chose comme ça ?
La République.
La République. Voilà. Donc en fait, non,
l'État, il y a enfin, il y a pour moi
l'État, c'est les citoyens. C'est-à-dire
c'est à la charge de la collectivité.
Ces maladies nous coûtent collectivement
très cher et vont nous coûter de plus en
plus cher. Mais le coût c'est une chose,
mais il faut voir aussi la détresse des
gens, le mal-être, la dépression, euh
toute cette difficulté à vivre quand on
est obèse, à se déplacer, à faire du
sport, la la dégradation de l'image de
soi. Enfin, donc voilà, c'est vrai que
c'est un drame pour la collectivité,
mais c'est surtout un drame pour les
personnes.
Ça prend quelle forme ? Est-ce que les
gens sont addictes à la malbouffe ?
Parce que c'est ça leur fait sécréter
des endorphines, pas d'endorphine. Ça
leur fait sécréter des choses qui les
qui leur permet qui leur permett de
se sentir mieux un temps ? Est-ce que
c'est parce que on la malbouffe est
chargée de choses très addictives dedans
? Je je fais mon candide. Est-ce que
vous avez analysé ou fait faire analyser
ou est-ce que vous êtes au courant de ce
que ce que vous jugez comme malbouffe ?
Tout dépend si on si on se replace. Si
si je me si je me rappelle quand quand
moi j'étais euh j'étais dans les dans
les entreprises qui réellement faisait
de la malbouffe, on connaissait toutes
ces études. Enfin quand j'en discutais,
des études faites par qui, payé comment
?
Toutes les études scientifiques, enfin
en fait si vous voulez, je discutais
beaucoup moi en tant qu'ingénieur mais
aux achats avec d'autres ingénieurs dans
la red. C'était c'était mon pendant
technique si vous voulez dans
l'entreprise puisque toutes les formules
étaient définies par la RED et la RD à
la tête de la RD c'était un ingénieur ou
un PhD donc ou un docteur en
alimentaire. Et ces gens-là
comme tout scientifique qui se
respectent se tiennent informés de tout
ce qui sort, toutes les études qui
sortent sur les ingrédients, la
technologie, les emballages, enfin tout
ce qui peut concerner de près ou de loin
leur travail. Donc on sait pertinemment
depuis de nombreuses années que les
sucres sont addictifs, surtout le
fructose. Donc ça pour nous c'est enfin
je le sais depuis peut-être 20 ans. Donc
euh donc on sait très bien que ces
produits-là sont très addictifs, que le
sucre est addictif, que les matières
grasses sont addictives, que le sel est
addictif et d'autant plus par chance
pour nous ces produits-l sont
extrêmement peu chers.
Donc fabriquer de la malbouffe, c'est
rentable, c'est apprécié par les
consommateurs, c'est peu cher à
fabriquer. On trouve ces ingrédients en
grosse quantité, donc pour faire des
grosses séries, c'est extrêmement
facile. Ensuite, l'industrie de la
malbouffe, c'est souvent partir de ce
qu'on appelle des des ingrédients
monofonctionnels, c'est-à-dire un
ingrédient qui a vraiment une fonction.
On fait un assemblage et tout ça est
standardisé, automatisé. on fait des
grosses usines, ça crache du produit
pour pas cher et on livre des des des
supermarchés par semiemorque, par bateau
et euh enfin voilà l'industrie dans
toute sa splendeur.
Pour ce livre, est-ce que vous avez
consulté les scientifiques ? Est-ce que
vous êtes fait relire ? Est-ce que
bah ce livre c'est 2 ans d'enquête, j'ai
vraiment passé 2 ans. Alors, j'ai
rencontré énormément de personnes, j'ai
rencontré des fournisseurs parce que le
fait d'être encore en activité et c'est
pour ça que je m'accroche aujourd'hui
malgré la surcharge de travail pour
écrire, pour enfin par toutes mes
activités, je tiens à rester en
activité. Ça me donne l'opportunité
d'entrer dans les usines, de voir les
techniciens, de de vérifier mes
certitudes, même des fois de changer
d'opinion sur pas mal de sujets. Euh
donc oui, j'ai rencontré des
fournisseurs, des scientifiques, des
d'autres lanceurs d'alerte. J'ai discuté
beaucoup avec Yasmine Motard Gémy, donc
l'ancienne directrice sécurité monde de
Nesley. Donc j'ai rencontré énormément
de monde.
Alors attention avec les noms hein.
Oui mais là il y a pas de il y a pas de
diffamation. C'est non, c'est une c'est
devenu une amie, quelqu'un que
j'apprécie beaucoup euh extrêmement
courageuse. Donc non non, je n'ai que du
bien à dire de cette dame. Durant cette
enquête, vous avez visité des usines,
vous avez vu quoi ? Quelle perception
ont les gens ? Et d'ailleurs, on vous
posera des questions sur l'augmentation
du coût énergétique ou
en Asie, en Europe,
volontiers. Volontiers.
Allez-y, je vous lance.
Alors, il faut différencier deux choses.
J'ai fait beaucoup de visites d'usine et
de visites dans le cadre de mon travail
et pour ce livre. Donc voilà. Donc en 2
ans, j'ai pas travaillé que sur ce
livre-là. Mais ce que j'ai vu pour ce
livre-là dans la problématique pour moi
était de de d'essayer de d'expliquer en
fait pour revenir à l'origine de ce
livre, quand j'ai fait mon premier livre
en 2015, ce que je voulais faire c'était
dire voilà il y a des mauvaises
pratiques dans l'agroalimentaire, je le
sais. Ceux qui travaillent dans
l'agroalimentaire le savent, les
représentants le savent. Genre des
lasages
faisons quelque chose
genre les lasagnes au cheval.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais ça, il y a eu
aucune surprise, c'était pas nouveau ça.
Tout le on le savait que ça se
pratiquait, mais ça se pratiquait pour
les lasagnes, tout ce que j'ai décrit
dans mon premier livre, les lasagnes, le
miel, la tomate, les champignons, les
épices, enfin on on je savais et
beaucoup tout le monde savait dans le
milieu qu'il y avait énormément de
fraude. Il suffit de lire les rapports
de la DGCRF, il suffit de lire les
rapports de l'Union européenne. Donc, on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de fraudes
depuis très longtemps. Euh,
pourquoi il y a ces fraudes ?
Parce que il y a pas parce que c'est mal
contrôlé, parce qu'il y a jamais de
sanction. parce qu'il y a pas de
sanction parce que parce que ça rapporte
parce que ça rapporte gros
parce que voilà si vous savez que sur
autoroute vous pouvez rouler à 150 et
vous êtes que quand vous êtes attrapé on
vous laisse faire qu'il y a jamais
d'amende jamais de retraite de permis
bah voilà vous êtes pas incité
réellement à respecter les règles.
Il y a pas une conscience
certainement si mais d'un autre côté il
faut voir que beaucoup de fraudes ne
sont pas dangereuses
et tous ne fraudent pas
tous ne fraudent pas. Non c'est vrai.
Tous ne fraudent pas et même ceux qui
fraudent ne frottent pas tout le temps
surtout. Donc il y a ça aussi. Moi j'ai
connu des entreprises où ça fraudait à
certains moments et puis à d'autres non
parce qu'on s'était fait repérer.
Donc voilà la la conscience. Bon ben j'y
crois j'y crois peu.
Il faut savoir aussi que ben dehors
c'est c'est c'est la compétition, c'est
la jungle. C'estàd que les voilà il y a
peu de il y a peu de clients, il y a
cinq supermarchés en France et il y a
des milliers d'entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire. On se bagarre entre
nous, on se bagarre contre les
importations, on se bagarre contre les
étrangers. Donc il y a une compétition
sévère, il y a des marges qui sont
faibles. L'industrie française, elle est
écrasée de charge si on compare par
rapport aux industries ne serait-ce
qu'Allemande. Donc en fait
ça va peut-être changer là
pour pour l'instant pour l'instant c'est
encore le cas. Pour l'instant c'est
encore le cas. Donc on verra demain ce
que ça ce que ça va être. Mais
donc euh donc voilà donc la question au
départ voilà ce livre. Donc ce que je
voulais faire au départ, c'est faire
changer les choses. Et ce qui s'est
passé, c'est qu'en fait, j'ai eu
énormément d'animosité, une fin de non
recevoir, euh des communiqués
incendiaires, des insultes, des menaces
de procès, enfin bon bref, j'étais
extrêmement surpris de la réaction
négative de l'industrie et des
représentants
et ça m'a mis beaucoup de temps
réellement à le comprendre. J'étais
extrêmement naïf mais finalement j'ai
compris que et aussi par rapport à des
articles qui sont parus assez récemment
notamment dans la presse anglaise
où des industriels de la malbouffe
reconnaissaient que une grosse partie de
leur portfolio de leur gamme était de la
malbouffe et que ils ne pouvaient rien
faire pour l'améliorer. C'est-à-dire,
ils sont allés tellement loin dans la
malbouffe, tellement loin dans l'ajout
de sucre, d'additif, de colorant, de de
matière grasse et cetera, que revenir en
arrière était quasi pas possible pour
faire un produit qui soit qualifié comme
sain, par exemple, par le Nutriscor ou
par d'autres d'autres critères de de
santé.
Nutriscore, c'est quoi ?
C'est une c'est une notation des
qualités nutritionnelles d'un produit.
C'est genre A B C D, c'est ça ? C'est
ça. Il y a des lettres et il y a aussi
une couleur. Donc il y a des couleurs.
C'estàd vert pour les produits de bonne
qualité ou de bonne qualité
nutritionnelle. Il faut préciser parce
que la qualité c'est c'est c'est flou.
Et et donc jusqu'à rouge pour les
produits de mauvaise qualité. Et je
crois qu'il y a cinq lettres dans ce
c'est pas mauvaise qualité, c'est
mauvais pour votre santé ou mauvais si
on en mange trop.
Voilà c'est ça. Mauvais si on en abuse.
C'est-à-dire que une huile par exemple 1
L d'huile ou 1 kg de sucre sera
forcément de de mauvaise qualité entre
guillemets nutritionnelle. Mais c'est un
ingrédient. On n'est pas censé en
consommer toute la journée. Donc
et en grande quantité.
Exactement. Et en grande quantité. Donc
il faut il faut faire la part des
choses. Euh il y a eu une cabale mené
par un industriel de la de de
l'agroalimentaire
en contre le Nutriscore en disant voilà
pour les produits traditionnels comme le
Rockfort par exemple, il faudrait une
dispense,
ce qui est normal.
Pourquoi ? Bah
le Rockfort
bah oui mais si le Rockfort le Rockfort
par définition est un produit est un
produit excellent. Moi moi je suis
absolument un inconditionnel mais
le myélium le mycélium qui est à
l'intérieur c'est c'est bon pour la
santé.
Oui tout à fait c'est oui c'est bon.
C'est un produit très bon. C'est un
produit goûteux. C'est un produit
traditionnel. Ça fait vivre des
entreprises françaises. C'est un produit
français reconnu. Donc
le larsac
voilà les Larsac les C le bleu desc
enfin tous ces produitsl sont
d'excellents produits. Mais si on ouvre
la porte pour ce produit là ça veut dire
l'ouvrir aussi pour je sais pas les
sardines en conserve pour un produit un
produit un produit un produit.
C'est-à-dire que les gens sont pas sont
pas idiots les consommateurs, ils savent
très bien que les fromages c'est c'est
salé, c'est gras, que les sardines en
conserve et ben il y a de l'huile
dedans. Donc ça peut pas avoir un
nutriscore extrêmement positif mais on
mange peu de rfort, on mange peu de
sardines à l'huile et et les gens font
la part des choses.
Et pour le reste, ils le font pas.
Le reste
c'est quoi le tout tout ? Non,
c'est-à-dire que pour un plat préparé,
l'intérêt, c'est quand vous voulez
comparer des produits d'une même gamme.
Vous voulez comparer deux pizzas, deux
plats préparés, et bien vous allez vous
dire entre deux pizzas, bon ben celle-ci
par exemple a de la charcuterie, du
pepperoni ou je sais pas et elle est
classée elle est classée rouge. Euh
celle-ci est au crudité, elle est
classée elle est classée orange. Je vais
plutôt prendre la orange à la rouge.
C'est une incitation, c'est une
information en fait. C'est simplement
une traduction claire du tableau
nutritionnel qui est obligatoire sur les
emballages. Donc les industriels
normalement devraient pas avoir sans
inquiéter. On
vous a consulté pour essayer de
d'améliorer le nutriscore ou de le faire
évoluer ?
Non non non parce que ça a été développé
par l'équipe de de Serge Werberg. Bon
j'écorche toujours le nom mais c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement compétent, de
brillant. C'est un médecin
nutritionniste qui connaît son affaire
donc non je lui fais confiance.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez commis d'autre
dans ce livre ?
Donc là, on était à 2015.
Oui.
Vous en avez fait combien d'autres à
C'est le 4e celui-ci.
C'est le 4e. Donc les les deux autres
les deux précédents.
Bon, en fait, si vous voulez, le
deuxième était une continuation du
premier avec des conseils parce qu'en
fait quand j'avais fait le premier, je
pensais pas en faire d'autres. Je
pensais que ma carrière de entre
guillemets de de d'aire très modestement
s'arrêterait là. Et puis on m'a dit "Ah
mais c'est pas mal, mais est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu pourrais nous
conseiller ?" Ça revenait, ça revenait
régulièrement. Donc mon éditeur m'a dit
"Ça peut-être pas mal de faire un livre
de conseil par rapport toi tu connais
l'industrie, tu connais les produits en
général on entend toujours des gens
parler mais qui ont jamais mis les pieds
dans une usine. Toi tu sais comment
c'est fait ? Est-ce que tu pourrais
expliquer comment on doit choisir, de
quoi on doit se méfier ?" Donc ça a été
le 2è. Euh ensuite,
j'ai fait un bouquin sur le bio parce
que c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse. Moi
je suis
parler d'ailleurs
voilà, je suis un ferment défenseur du
bio et cetera. Et donc voilà, je c'est
un sujet qui m'intéressait beaucoup et
je me suis rendu compte que ceux qui en
parlaient que enfin bon, y compris des
écologistes puisque c'est lié à ça, euh
ne savaient pas ce que c'était. Donc ça
m'a intéressé. Je me suis plongé dedans
et j'ai fait un livre là-dessus qui m'a
qui m'a vraiment passionné, qui m'a pris
2 ans également. Et celui-ci c'était
vraiment, j'avais toujours en tête mais
pourquoi pourquoi je me prends autant de
menaces ? Pourquoi je me reçois des
courriers d'avocats dès que j'ouvre la
bouche ? J'ai reçu encore un courrier en
en août dernier parce que j'avais osé
critiquer un mélange d'épices qui était
fraudé en plus
et finalement je me suis Bah voilà.
La preuve qu'il était fraudé.
Oui parce que je l'ai goûté.
Ah mais ça c'est pas une preuve.
Non non mais laisse-moi finir mon
histoire.
Je participais à un documentaire sur des
mélanges d'épices. Donc on m'a dit "Bah
voilà, est-ce que tu pourrais regarder
les mélanges et puis nous dire ce que tu
en penses ?" Je dis "OK, mais attention,
pas de nom, pas de marque, pas de on
floute et cetera." Donc on prend toutes
les précautions, pas de dénigrement, pas
voilà donc ça c'était les règles que je
m'applique systématiquement.
On m'a dit "Oui, pas de problème, on
fera bien attention. Le but c'est de on
veut pas démolir personne, c'est juste
de parler du produit." Donc on fait
goûter quelques produits et puis parmi
eux, j'en goûte un qui était euh
caractéristique ou très similaire à des
produits fraudé que j'ai connu. J'ai
quand même été acheteur des pistes.
Vous avez le Covid ou pas ?
Ouais.
Est-ce que ça a changé votre goût ?
C'était avant ou après le Covid ?
Je ne pense pas que ça allait changer.
Euh
c'était récent. C'était récent. Alors
mais je essayie de me rappeler quand
j'ai eu le Covid. J'ai eu le covid il y
a pas très longtemps. Après mes trois
injections, je pensais être en sécurité
mais je me suis chopé le covid et je
suis resté au lit pendant 3 jours.
Vous auriez pu terminer en ça aurait pu
être pire.
Ouais, je sais pas, je sais pas. Enfin
bref, [raclement de gorge]
vous avez entendu parler de cette
histoire de la des usines de pizza bien
cracra qui a rendu malade y compris moi
d'ailleurs. J'ai passé j'ai passé ça
faisait peut-être 15 ans 10 ans que
j'avais pas mangé de de pizza surgelé.
Ah là là une touriste.
Ah bon ?
Oh là là.
C'est pas une pizza gastro, c'était
gastroentérique. [raclement de gorge]
Ah bah là c'était une pizza au caca là.
C'était Pardon. Désolé. Vous avez
entendu ça ? Est-ce que vous avez évité
des des usines ?
Oui, dans les groupes où j'ai travaillé,
il y avait des usines de pizza. Oui, on
a fabriqué de pizzas et des des usines
où c'était salle partout de Vous avez vu
les images de cette usine ?
J'ai vu les photos.
Comment on peut avoir ça en France sans
qu'il y ait
un contrôle vétérinaire ?
Personnellement, bon, les contrôles, il
y a il y a quasiment pas de contrôle. Il
y a de moins en moins de contrôle. Je
Pourquoi il y a de moins en moins de
contrôle ? parce que il y a plus de
moyens, on coupe les vivres au aux
organismes qui sont aux autorités qui
sont censées contrôler et assurer la
sécurité alimentaire. On pourrait parler
de la DGCRF, donc les fraudes. On
pourrait parler aussi de la DGL, enfin
la direction générale de l'alimentation.
Ces gens-là voient leur budget réduit
d'année en année, leurs effectifs fond.
Je crois que les les fraudes ont perdu
un quart de leur effectif en 10 ans.
Enfin, on leur on on les rend
inopérants. Dernièrement, les
contrôleurs de des GRF sont passés sous
l'autorité du ministère, donc ils sont
passés du ministère de l'économie, je
crois, au ministère de la culture qui a
vraiment aucun intérêt à ce que les
contrôles ça.
Ah oui, tout à fait. Oui.
Ah oui, oui. La partie contrôle, elle a
changé le ministère. Donc
tout est fait si vous voulez pour
complètement
euh vider de toute substance et de toute
possibilité d'action ces organismes pour
qui personnellement j'ai le plus grand
respect parce que je les ai connu, ils
m'ont fait des misères à une époque.
Vous méritiez ou pas ?
Oui oui tout à fait. Non mais c'est
enfin ce qui est fou c'est que les
fonctionnaires en France en général sont
des gens formés, compétents, motivés,
honnêtes
et sympa la plupart du temps qui
Oui. Enfin voilà donc et qui connaissent
leur métier en général donc voilà mais
quand ils peuvent pas agir
misère par rapport au privés.
Oui exactement bien sûr bien sûr. Mais
quand il quand on leur tout moyen de
travailler, le budget, leur moyen de
fonctionnement,
ils peuvent rien faire. Ils sont
complètement démunis. Et aujourd'hui la
l'optique c'est de confier aux
entreprises qu'on appelle les
autocontrôles. Et on voit le résultat,
on l'a très bien vu avec les pizzas et
on voilà. Donc si jamais il y a jamais
aucun inspecteur qui vient contrôler ce
qui se passe et ben bon voilà, on fait
dans cette usine, ils avaient appliqué
ce qu'ils appellent la méthode lin.
Alors lig en anglais ça veut dire
maigre. Donc ça veut dire il faut
supprimer tout ce qui est gras. Voilà
tout ce qui est inutile entre
guillemets. Et perdre du temps à
nettoyer bah c'est inutile, ça coûte de
l'argent. Voilà. et on voit le résultat
parce que parce que c'est une méthode.
C'est quoi ? C'est c'est la la méthode
euh
Oui, c'est les c'est les fameuses
méthodes soi-disant de de gestion de la
qualité merveilleuse à la Japonaise là,
tu sais le Camban, les toutes ces toutes
ces méthodes des gourous japonais pour
expliquer comment il faut faire de la
qualité, comment comment on gère une
entreprise, c'està-dire il faut être
entreprises japonaises. D'habitude,
elles sont toujours super propres. Oui,
bien sûr, mais il y a un moment donné,
c'est que quand vous enlevez le gras,
d'accord, c'est bien, mais après vous
arrivez au muscle et quand vous enlevez
le muscle, vous arrivez à l'os quoi.
C'est à un moment donné, il faut il faut
s'arrêter, il faut savoir où est où est
le le le mauvais gras.
Alors le le là, on on traverse une
période d'inflation.
Ouais.
Est-ce que ça va avoir ça va avoir des
répercussions sur l'agroalimentaire ?
Là, on voit ce que certains produits
bah comme les œufs ont pris 20 %, bah
ils se débrouillent pour mettre autre
chose que des œufs.
Bien sûr,
pour que le prix reste à peu près
stable. Il y a une un rétrécissement des
produits. C'estd que c'est le même
paquet mais il y en a un peu moins
dedans. Le grammage change pour éviter
que les ça avait commencé depuis
longtemps ça.
Oui. Est-ce ça ça va avoir un impact de
quel type à votre avis ?
Bah si la situation continue c'estàd que
si on narrive pas à solutionner ce
problème de coût d'énergie oui il y aura
un impact. Il y aura un impact
forcément. On peut effectivement
modifier la recette des ingrédients
moins chers mais enfin le le la tendance
avait été lancée depuis très longtemps
déjà. C'estàd que on a déjà des produits
souvent de qualité très médiocre. Euh et
puis on peut pas remplacer la farine
dans le pain, on peut pas mettre de la
suure de bois non plus. Donc donc
pareil, diminuer les grammages,
d'accord, mais si vous si vous achetez
un produit qui est plus faible en
grammage, vous allez devoir manger plus
d'autre chose parce que vous il vous
faut votre quantité de calories.
Donc non, ça c'est pas ça c'est des
c'est pas des solutions. Ça va peut-être
aider l'industriel à baisser ses coûts
par unité et puis à à à protéger ses
profits et sa marge.
Peut-être ses employés.
Peut-être ses employés. Oui. Mais le
vrai problème, c'est qu'il faut qu'on
trouve une solution pour baisser le coût
de l'énergie parce que de toute façon
l'agroalimentaire, les marges en
agroalimentaires sont extrêmement
faibles. Moi j'ai travaillé dans des
entreprises qui travaillaient à moins de
10 % de marge. Donc c'est extrêmement
faible. Je vois aujourd'hui dans les
produits les produits de pharmacie, les
vaccins et cetera, on est sur des marges
qui dépassent à 50 %. On n'est pas du
tout sur les mêmes industries. Donc les
industries et les la marge dans
l'agroalimentaire est extrêmement
faible. Si les matières premières
explosent en prix avec la le les
monopoles de la grande distribution, au
final vous pouvez pas vous en sortir. Il
y aura forcément une inflation sur les
prix ou alors il y aura les entreprises
qui vont disparaître.
On entend ce qui n'est pas sourcé pas
vérifié mais on commence à entendre des
bruits de couloir sur fin 2023. Le cadit
de la ménagère, le cadit moyen de la
ménagère risque de prendre entre 30 et
40 % d'inflation. Est-ce que ça vous
semble déconnant ? Non, non, non, pas du
tout, pas du tout. Quand vous avez
Alors, ça dépend réellement du type
d'industrie.
Par exemple, en ce qui nous concerne, on
fait beaucoup de produits différents.
Pour les produits à forte valeur
ajoutée, type les vaccins par exemple,
il y aura très peu d'incidences parce
que en fait la valeur du produit, c'est
surtout de la connaissance, de la Red et
cetera. Donc le type de produit où il y
a beaucoup de matière grise euh ou
d'investissement sera assez peu touché.
Par contre, les produits où il y a
beaucoup de consommation énergétique,
alors ceux-là oui sont seront énormément
impactés. Tout ce qui est industrie de
la déshydratation, donc les légumes
déshydratés, ces choses-là seront
impactées. Euh les productions agricoles
seront impactées si on a une forte
demande alimentaire aussi, ce sera ce
sera aussi impacté. Euh il y a aussi un
lien entre très fort entre énergie et
production agricole puisqueen France il
faut savoir qu'à peu près 5 % de la de
la SAU
la la surface agricole utile
euh 5 % de la surface agricole on va
dire est utilisée pour ce qu'on appelle
les agrocarburants. Donc c'est autant de
surface qui ne sera pas disponible pour
l'alimentation.
Donc avoir une hausse du panier de la
ménagère de cet ordre là ne me paraît
pas impossible. Effectivement
à votre avis les industriels, ils vont
réagir comment ? Ils vont se mettre à
l'éolienne
alors ça peut pas se faire à si court
terme. C'est c'estàd que
les industriels,
c'est pas eux enfin ça dépend
l'industriel producteur d'énergie.
Alors, je sais pas EDF total et cetera,
ils vont certainement dans dans un
avenir proche trouver des solutions ou
enfin mais construire une centrale,
c'est pareil, ça fait une centrale
nucléaire, ça prend des des des années
et des années. Donc l'industriel
alimentaire, lui, il fera que subir.
Changer une ligne, ça prend des années.
Aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui, il y a une
pénurie de matériaux, par exemple.
Enfin, je sais, nous, on construit des
usines, donc on manque d'acier, on
manque de verre, on manque de tout. Donc
tous les projets industriels aujourd'hui
prennent du retard. Quand on achète une
machine, on voulait acheter un extrudeur
il y a pas très longtemps.
C'est quoi un extrudeur ? C'est une
machine qui cuit sous pression. C'est
avec ça qu'on fait tout ce qui est les
produits les produits fluffy là, les
snacks apéritifs par exemple, les
croquettes de chien, tout ça c'est fait
c'est fait avec un extrudeur. Voilà,
les produits apéritifs, les croquettes
de chien.
Oui, c'est la même machine. C'est la
même technologie. Donc on fait une
purée, les les flocons de les les
cordflex. Voilà, on fait une purée, on
la met sous pression, on chauffe à forte
température.
C'est quoi ? Quelle température ?
Je sais pas 160° 180°. Enfin, on peut
monter très haut parce que c'est sous
pression.
Et euh donc la pression monte. Alors ça
dépend des procédés, ça dépend des
machines et cetera. Ça peut monter je
sais pas peut-être à 10, 15 barres, 20
barres, je sais pas. Et après en sortie
de machine quand ça quand ça quand ça
sort à l'air libre, ça s'expense. Donc
le l'eau immédiatement se vaporise et on
a un produit avec une structure très
alvéolée, très légère. Donc voilà, pour
acheter ce type de machine maintenant,
il vous faut plus d'un an.
Donc ce que je veux dire c'est que les
industriels ont besoin de temps pour
s'adapter et la crise est arrivée
extrêmement vite. Les hausses de prix de
l'énergie, du transport ont été
extrêmement brutales et je vois pas
d'industrie capable de de ne pas
répercuter les prix aujourd'hui.
Ça va être une boucherie.
Bah ça dépend où. Ça dépend où ? Comme
comme je te disais, j'étais en Malaisie
la semaine dernière hein, donc j'ai j'ai
discuté avec des fournisseurs locaux en
leur disant bah voilà qu'en est-il pour
vous de l'énergie ? Donc les
fournisseurs que j'ai vu m'ont dit bah
nous on utilise du gaz naturel. Donc je
dis voilà gaz naturel c'est horrible. Il
dit bah non parce que la Malaisie on
produit un petit peu puis de toute façon
on en importe et puis de toute façon le
gouvernement il stabilise les prix. Donc
il dit pour nous pas d'incidence
ou très peu
ou très il m'a dit pas d'incidence. Donc
je sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas. Je lui
a priori je lui fass confiance. Il était
pas inquiet. Alors je lui ai dit bah
nous en Europe ça va pas être facile.
C'est pas grave on vous livrera.
Ça va faire de la concurrence, ça c'est
bien.
J'ai bien peur que l'industrie
européenne et française en paye les peau
cassé.
Revenons à la malbouffe. H
vaut mieux être chimiste pour travailler
dans l'agroalimentaire. Non,
il vaut mieux, il vaut mieux, j'allais
dire, il vaut mieux pas travailler dans
l'agroalimentaire ou pas travailler dans
la malbouffe. Je pense qu'on s'emporte
beaucoup mieux.
Pourquoi il faut pas travailler dans
l'agroalimentaire ? Faut bien donner à
manger aux gens.
Disons que les c'est très si comme moi
on est passionné par l'alimentation, par
la bouffe, par la bonne bouffe depuis
tout petit, il faut pouvoir avoir le le
budget pour avoir tout ça.
Oui, mais il y a comme tu disais, il y a
des entreprises qui travaillent bien, on
fait quand même des bons produits et
cetera.
Mais dans l'industrie, c'est quand même
difficile de trouver du haut de gamme ou
du très haut de gamme. Et c'est ce dont
moi je rêvais quand j'étais plus jeune.
Et quand j'ai était dans l'industrie,
quand moi j'avais une par exemple, je
rêvais d'acheter des épices. Par
exemple, je pensais que les épices
c'était des produits précieux importer
du bout du monde et en fait quand
j'étais dans les épices, je me suis
rendu compte que le poivre ça valait 1 2
3 3 € du kilo, que il y avait beaucoup
de mélange, beaucoup de fraudes de
mauvaise qualité, que c'était un produit
comme un autre finalement.
Donc voilà et puis si c'est pour pour
travailler comme ingénieur, enfin comme
comme j'ai fait moi, pour ensuite faire
des produits qui rendent les gens
malades, non, c'est quelque part c'est
qui peuvent rendre les gens malades
qui qui peuvent Oui. Non, certains
pourraient rendre les gens malades. Oui.
Oui. Avec toutes les précautions du
jazz, bien entendu.
Le bio hm
h
est-ce qu'on fait un petit détour par le
bio ? Le bio c'est bon. Le bio il y a
des fraudes le bio qu'est-ce qui se
passe
par ? Il y a beaucoup en dire sur le
bio. Donc déjà pour dire pour être très
clair, moi je suis un fervant défenseur
du bio. Je consomme bio autant que
possible
parce que vous pouvez vous permettre
financièrement.
Il y a ça aussi. Oui, c'est vrai, il y a
ça. Et puis aussi parce que c'est une
garantie supplémentaire de qualité entre
un produit conventionnel et
bioéquivalent,
c'est-à-dire produit au même endroit,
pas importer du bout du monde, mais
voilà. Euh le fait de d'utiliser moins
ou pas d'engrais de synthèse et de
pesticides de pesticides chimiques fait
que c'est meilleur pour la santé et pour
l'environnement. Voilà. Ceci dit, le
cahier des charges du bio selon moi, il
est il est très insuffisant et c'est
pour ça qu'on a aussi aujourd'hui autant
de labels privés bio qui vont au-delà.
Donc par exemple les biocohérences,
naturel, progrès, démèr et cetera. Donc
c'est bien mais pourrait facilement et
largement faire mieux.
C'est quoi les les je vais pas dire les
petites magouilles mais c'est quoi les
petits arrangements qu'on peut se
permettre avec le bio ? Est-ce qu'il y a
des pays qui sont labellisés bio qui
nous envoient des des choses qui sont
pas très bio ? Est-ce qu'il y a des
bananes du bout du monde qui sont censé
être bio mais en fait elles sont pas
très bio ?
Ah oui oui tout à fait. Pour mon livre
du bio par exemple, je m'étais amusé.
J'avais appelé des fournisseurs en leur
disant "Bah voilà en gros je veux
acheter du bio mais je veux pas payer le
prix."
Je m'étais amusé. Qui me dit ?
Non mais je dire je vais pas écrire
n'importe quoi. Je je dis des choses que
je sais que j'ai vu où j'ai j'ai la
chance de travailler et je travaille
aussi pour pouvoir avoir accès à ces
gens-là.
Vous gagnez combien en ce moment ?
Je gagne beaucoup moins qu'à Singapour.
C'est la misère. C'est énorme. C'est
raisonnable. Pas assez mais raisonnable.
Je vous laisse terminer. Donc le bio.
Donc en bref, quand j'ai fait mon livre
sur le bio, je me suis dit bon on va on
va je savais être je savais où je
mettais les pieds, je savais plus ou
moins ce que ça allait donner mais bon,
je me suis dit je vais appeler des
fournisseurs pour voir si je peux
acheter du phu bio. J'ai appelé des
fournisseurs en Chine. Je leur ai dit
voilà parce que je savais que c'était en
Chine que ça se passait. Je savais sur
quel produit. Donc je les appelle. Je
dis voilà, je vais de la graine de
tournesol, c'est pour l'alimentation
animale parce que je sais que
l'alimentation animale, c'est beaucoup
moins regardé, beaucoup moins contrôlé.
Je leur ai dit voilà c'est simple, je
veux acheter des produits bio avec les
documents qui vont bien mais j'ai pas
les moyens de payer du bio. Voilà il a
deux ou trois qui m'ont rappelé pour me
dire c'est difficile
et l'écart de prix normal qui était au
début je sais plus de 20 % assez
rapidement il est tombé à 8 %. On m'a
dit c'est la c'est le minimum qu'on
puisse te faire pour avoir le produit
avec document.
Jamais on a dit c'est du faux bio et
cetera et cetera mais entre nous c'était
très clair et c'est pas possible d'avoir
un produit bio avec un écart de prix à 8
%.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher de
faire du bio. Ça coûte parce que vous
par exemple au niveau des engrais vous
pouvez pas avoir d'engrais chimique. Or
l'engrais naturel coûte extrêmement cher
par rapport à l'engrais chimique. Pareil
pour les produits de traitement. les
produits de traitement coûtent beaucoup
plus cher et j'en sais quelque chose
puisque là où je travaille aujourd'hui,
on fait des produits pour la la culture
biologique. Euh pareil, il faut plus de
main d'œuvre, le rendement est
inférieur, enfin produire bio, ça coûte
plus cher et 8 % c'est pas suffisant
surtout pour ces produitsl.
Et c'était pour quelle quantité que vous
vous le faux le faux vrai bio là ?
J'avais demandé pour quelques
containers. Alors je sais plus la
quantité que j'avais demandé mais
quelques containers sinon en dessous
c'est pas sérieux.
C'était dans quel c'était dans quel pays
?
Chine.
Chine ?
Ouais.
Ils ont l'habitude de faire des choses
comme ça.
Bah
je suppose que oui. Enfin, moi je l'ai
trouvé très facilement et j'avais fait
ça parce que j'avais fait ça sur ce
produit là parce que j'avais vu une
étude de l'université allemande de
Kessel qui avait mis un une nouvelle
méthode d'analyse sur les isotopes de
l'azote justement parce qu'en fait la
plus grosse fraude dans
l'agroalimentaire dans l'agroalimentaire
bio, c'est d'utiliser des des engrais de
synthèse puisque les pesticides on peut
les retrouver, on les analyse, on les
retrouve. Par contre, utiliser de
l'engrais de synthèse, ça il y a pas de
méthode aujourd'hui pour les détecter et
c'est extrêmement facile. Au lieu de
mettre un engrais un engrais naturel,
vous mettez un engrais de synthèse. Et
donc l'université
un engrais basé sur du gaz
basé sur de sur du gaz du méthane du
voilà, c'est purement purement fossile.
Donc c'est pollution, problème
énergétique. Bon justement, on peut en
parler avec la crise actuelle hein.
L'engrais voilà le coup de l'engrais va
exploser d'ailleurs
a déjà explosé.
Oui oui oui. Donc le le l'énergie
vraiment est à la base de tout. Et c'est
Charles Gaffe que tu as déjà reçu qui
dit l'économie c'est l'énergie
transformée. Donc l'énergie est à la
base de tout. Et pour finir avec cette
histoire là, donc l'université de Cassel
avait analysé l'isotope de l'azote
puisqueen fait l'azote l'azote lourd,
l'azote léger, l'azote 15 et voilà. Et
en fait la l'azote chimique contient de
l'azote atmosphérique qui est de l'azote
léger, on va dire beaucoup plus que
l'azote l'azote lourd qu'on peut trouver
au niveau du sol. et ils avaient
démontré qu'à peu près 80 % des produits
chinois qu'ils avaient testés dont des
graines de tournesol 80 % avaient été
cultivés avec de avec de l'engrais de
l'engré de synthèse. J'ai appelé des
fournisseurs, j'ai appelé dans la région
de Dalien dans le nord dans le nord,
j'avais trouvé des euh des négociants
dans ces produitsl à des prix
compétitifs et voilà très facilement en
quelques coups de téléphone ça s'est
fait.
C'est magnifique.
Très Ouai. Très facile. Vous
vous avez pas essayé d'acheter des
tomates en Chine ?
J'ai acheté des tomates pour de vrai.
Ouais. J'ai acheté les tomates pendant
des années.
C'était bien fait ? C'était c'était fait
comment ? Pas cher. C'était
Ah oui, pas cher. Oui oui. Ah oui, mais
il y a enfin c'est a un dumping un
dumping phénoménal. C'est-à-dire que
l'industrie chinoise de la tomate
c'était Kovko et Shalky. C'est c'était
des émanations pas de nom hein.
Non mais là je critique pas. C'est juste
que le nom des entreprises des plus gros
conglomérats qui fabriquaient de la
tomate hein. C'était des émanations des
des de l'armée populaire chinoise. Donc
c'était des des groupes d'état.
Euh c'était les autorités chinoises qui
payaient le transport entre le SJang et
le port. Euh donc voilà, donc quand ils
sont arrivés sur le marché, voilà, ils
sont dit "Bon, quel est quel est le prix
de marché de la tomate triple concentrée
? Le marché est à 1000 €. Bon bah OK,
nous on arrive, on le fait à 800. Voilà,
ils sont devenus numéro 1 quelques
années. Extrêmement facile.
Il y a des contrôles sur la main d'œuvre
?
Il y a des contrôles sur la main
d'œuvre, je pense pas. Non, si sinon ça
se saurait.
Le Sing, c'est pas là où il y a des
wigours.
C'est les wigours. Oui, tout à fait.
C'est c'est Ouais. Ouais, c'est lesour.
C'est lesour. C'est des très jeunes
personnes dans les champs. Donc
difficile de savoir quel âge ils ont
mais vraiment très jeunes. Donc oui, il
y a des problèmes dans ces dans ce pays
là, mais il y a des problèmes pour la
tomate. Ils font du coton également. Je
suppose qu'il y a les mêmes genres de
problèmes. Ils font plein d'autres
légumes. Donc oui, il y a beaucoup à
dire. Effectivement,
la sécurité alimentaire, ça vous parle ?
Ouais, tout à fait. Est-ce que vous
pensez que l'État français et l'Europe h
sont sur les le bon chemin pour assurer
la sécurité alimentaire européenne et
française ? Quand on voit le prix de le
prix des engrais augmenter ? Hm
hm.
Quand on voit certains agriculteurs qui
disent "Bon bah maintenant euh les
engrais coûtent trop cher, donc on va
pas planter ça." Quand on voit les
tomates qui poussent sous serre avec de
la lumière, [soupir]
ça va coûter 8 10 15 20 fois plus cher.
H
euh quand on voit l'approvisionnement
des matières premières qui vient de
compliqué, est-ce que vous pensez que
l'État a les capacités pour maintenir
une très bonne sécurité alimentaire ? Je
suis pas vraiment inquiet pour pour
l'Europe et pour la France en
particulier. On a quand même des gros
atouts hein. C'est-à-dire qu'en France,
on a une une surface agricole qui
dépasse les 50 %. Donc, on a vraiment
beaucoup de terres arables, de prairies
et cetera. Donc, la France est un grand
pays agricole. On a de la surface, on a
des paysans qui savent bien travailler,
donc je suis pas inquiet pour le pays.
Ensuite, on fait quand même encore
toujours, même si c'est de moins en
moins vrai partie des pays riches,
je dis de moins en moins vrai, mais euh
sentiment d'être riche peut-être,
mais je me sens plutôt solidaire avec
les Égyptiens par exemple ou des pays
comme ça qui euh qui auront beaucoup de
problèmes pour s'alimenter, qui ont déjà
des problèmes mais qui auront en auront
de plus en plus pour s'alimenter
correctement. En France, ce sera un
problème pour une partie de la
population, mais avec les aides
sociales, la redistribution, je pense
que en France, il y aura pas de il y
aura pas de crise de la fin, il y aura
pas d'émeutes de la fin. Alors que dans
des pays d'Afrique
ou des pays pauvres, enfin voilà, plus
pauvres que nous, oui, là ça pourrait
être dramatique.
Pourquoi ça va être dramatique ? Parce
qu'ils vont pas pouvoir acheter, parce
que leur monnaie va dévaluer parce que
l'augmentation des matières premières
alimentaires vont exploser. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'on va pas les livrer parce que
les céréales ukrainiens ukrainiennes ne
vont pas arriver jusqu'à eux vont être
J'ai pas j'ai pas de boule de cristal
donc je sais pas ce qui va se passer
avec la situation en Ukraine. C'est sûr
qu'il faudrait que ça se débloque. Donc
il y a un moment donné
céréales russes d'ailleurs.
Oui bah Russie Ukraine ils font partie
des trois ou quatre plus gros
exportateurs. Donc que ce soit les
céréales ou le tournesol enfin des
produits agricoles. Euh je pense que de
toute façon les exportations, la
production va continuer. la Russie pour
l'instant, ils sont pas ils sont pas
impactés. Ils ont tout ce qu'il faut,
ils ont du gaz, ils ont de la terre.
Enfin bref, la pollution agricole russe
va pas va pas s'effondrer. Donc les
Russes pourront toujours livrer.
L'Ukraine, je pense que malgré tout, la
production sera pas réduite à zéro du
jour au lendemain. Euh moi, j'ai
toujours l'expérience de la guerre en
Serbie quand quand il y a eu le le
bombardement en Serbie. Moi, j'achetais
des produits dans ces pays-là.
J'achetais par exemple de la griotte. On
sait pas mais la la Serbie est le plus
gros producteur de griillotte au monde.
Cerise
de cerise griote, la petite cerise acide
là. Donc ils en font de la conserve, ils
font des surgelés et cetera, on fait de
la purée. Enfin, ils se sont spécialisés
dans ce produit-là. Je sais pas
pourquoi, c'est le terroir peut-être ou
le savoir-faire. Et je me rappelle quand
il y avait les bombardements quand les
Américains avaient fait sauter le le
l'ambassade de Chine et quand il y avait
les ponts qui avaient
il avait pas ils avaient pas fait sauter
l'ambassade de Chine. Le bombardement
est arrivé juste à côté.
Voilà, c'était une un accident de frappe
chirurgicale, on va dire.
Voilà,
une de nos alliés américains,
c'est le chirurgien était borge.
Ça peut arriver.
Donc voilà, ce que je veux dire en en
résumant, c'est que des manchud
peut-être
dans le pire de la guerre quand il y
avait les bombardements, quand
l'ambassade chinoise avait explosé,
j'étais allé dans ce pays-là. Donc
l'aéroport de Belgrade était fermé mais
j'étais passé par l'aéroport le plus
proche d'à côté, je sais plus c'éit
Budapest ou quelque chose comme ça. Et
il y avait des navettes qui avaient été
mis en place entre les pays. J'y étais
allé, il y avait pas eu de souci.
J'étais allé voir mes fournisseurs, on
on avait passé enfin on avait passé la
frontière sans aucun problème et mes
camions donc mes contrats ont été livrés
en pleine guerre.
Donc ce que il y avait pas d'embargo, il
y avait rien.
Non, je pense pas. Je me souviens plus
vraiment. Ce que je peux dire, c'est que
j'ai jamais eu d'interruption de
livraison de la Serbie, y compris
pendant cette guerre là. Après, s'il y
avait un embargo, c'est possible mais il
suffisait que les Serbes ils me vendent
via avec peut-être pas la Turquie parce
que c'est pas la bonne direction, mais
il suffisait qu'il me vendent via une
entreprise suisse avec une facture
suisse et puis avec un certificat
d'origine hongrois par exemple et puis
voilà, ça passe.
Ça se fait ça des choses comme ça, des
certificats d'origine qui Oui, oui, ça
se fait. Oui, énormément. C'est
extrêmement facile.
Pourquoi c'est facile ? Parce qu'il y a
pas de contrôle. OK, mais comment ça se
fait ?
Il suffit de le certificat d'origine, il
suffit de le demander. Vous êtes une
entreprise française ou autre, vous
dites voilà, il me faut un certificat
d'origine pour tel produit, vous le
demandez. C'est un document
administratif en fait. Personne vient
chez vous vérifier que l'eau il est là,
que il y a pas d'inspection réellement.
Ah non, quand j'achète des containers
par exemple, je sais pas moi un produit,
je veux
j'achète plusieurs containers par jour.
Donc et chaque container est accompagné
d'un certificat d'origine qui indique de
quel pays vient le produit. Mais c'est
c'est administratif, il y a pas de vrai
contrôle sur place
avec les récessions mondiales qui est en
train d'arriver, le prix du contenur a
vachement baissé là depuis.
Il a beaucoup augmenté et baissé depuis.
Ouais. Ouais. C'estàdire que par exemple
un container que je faisais venir bah
tiens de Malaisie justement parce que
c'est c'est ce que j'ai en tête.
Malaisie États-Unis, je le payais
normalement 5000 dollars le container
c'est monté jusqu'à 15000 donc x 3 et
aujourd'hui c'est descendu à 10000. Donc
on n'est pas encore à la normale mais ça
a rebaissé pas mal.
Vous avez discuté avec des producteurs
d'huile de palme bio.
Oui. Ah bio ? Non pas bio.
C'est pas bio.
Non pas bio. Je pense pas que non mais
en fait on achète pas d'huile enfin moi
j'achète pas d'huile de palme. J'achète
un dérivé d'huile de palme. Et les
usines que j'ai visité sont des ce
qu'ils appellent des oléo chemicals. Des
des distilleries et des raffineries
d'huile de palme pour
pétrole en fait.
Exactement comme le pétrole. Donc on a
la même chose, hein. On a euh des des
craqueurs, on a des des tours de
distillation et on craque et on disyle
l'huile de palme comme on fait pour le
pétrole.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut spacer
l'huile de palme ?
Non, absolument pas. Absolument pas.
Avant avant on prenait pas d'huile de
palme.
Oui, mais avant la population était
était moins importante. Avant euh on
avait moins besoin de de de produits
naturels. C'estàd que l'huile de palme,
ça reste quand même un produit naturel.
Donc maintenant qu'on essaie de
remplacer le pétrole par des produits
naturels, l'huile de palme ça sert pour
à plein de choses. Ça sert comme
plastifiant, ça sert comme on fait ça
sert dans les comme comme désinfectant,
ça on fait du enfin énormément de
produits avec l'huile de pomme. On fait
le diester ou le ou le méthylester pour
les biocarburants, enfin pour les
agrocarburants. Euh donc il y a de
l'huile de palme dans 90 % des produits
de consommation courante dans les
shampoings, dans la cosmétique, dans
énormément de produits. Donc sans
passer, non, c'est impossible. Et euh
donc j'en discutais avec un fournisseur
en disant "Bah voilà, l'huile de palme
en Europe, c'est pas très bien vu.
Peut-être qu'on pense la la remplacer
par de l'huile de coco." Il me dit "Oh
là, si vous voulez, mais sachez que la
productivité des cocotiers, c'est cinq
fois moindre que les huiles de palme."
Donc en fait, si vous remplacez euh le
la surface nécessaire pour pour votre
huile de palme par de la coco, il faudra
cin fois plus de surface. Et bien,
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
écologique ? Le gars avec qui je
parlais, il me disait "Voilà, nous notre
entreprise, on a nos plantations, on a
350000 hectares 3500 hectares de
palmes de palmiers en Malaisie, en
Indonésie, au Liberia et je sais plus je
sais plus où." Il me dit "Si vous
remplacez ça par de la coco, du colzo,
il vous faudra cinq fois plus de
surface." Et il m'a dit et je suis un
fournisseur parmi une dizaine. Donc ce
passé du Le Palme, non, c'est pas du
tout réaliste aujourd'hui.
Sans augmentation des prix drastiques,
c'est ça ? sans augmentation et même
c'est pas forcément possible ou alors il
faudra les remplacer par des produits de
la chimie donc par des produits du
pétrole et avec les prix du pétrole euh
voilà ça exploserait.
Est-ce que en Malaisie ou dans ces
pays-là il y a du bio ?
Euh oui, ça se trouve. Oui. Oui, tout à
fait. Oui. Souvent du bio importé
d'ailleurs. Il y a beaucoup de bios
importés de d'Australie par exemple.
Australie en fait pas mal. Ensuite, il y
a eu des investissements qui se sont
faits. Il y a eu pas mal de productions
un peu spécifiques. Il y a eu du
bioproduit à Singapour. Il y a du groupe
ou du en Thaïlande par exemple. Oui, on
en trouve. C'est relativement encore
relativement marginal mais ça se trouve
avec les mêmes écarts de tarif qu'on a
en France
avec des écarts plus importants,
j'allais dire parce qu'en fait le le
marché du bio et la conscience de
l'alimentation en Asie est beaucoup
moins développée qu'en Europe. Donc ils
sont en retard de quelques années et la
diffusion de ces produits est beaucoup
plus faible. Donc il y a le marché est
plus petit, les marches sont plus
importantes, c'est plus restreint donc
les prix sont élevés.
Question internet que j'attrape à l'œil.
Pourquoi manger des produits transformés
dont la valeur nutritionnelle est zéro ?
Alors, c'est ça fait partie de la
question. Fraude ou pas fraude ? Alors,
il y a toujours il y a toujours quand
même quelque chose de nutritionnel dans
ces produitsl. Ouais, il faut il faut
pas il faut pas tout voilà, il faut pas
tout mélanger. C'est-à-dire que les
fraudes c'est faire des choses qui sont
illégales. Voilà, ça c'est c'est une
chose, mais on peut faire des fraudes
sur les produits bios, sur les produits
naturels, sur le vin, sur on peut faire
des fraudes sur tous les produits. Donc
voilà, ça c'est c'est une chose ça. Pas
ça pas forcément de lien avec la
malbouffe.
La malbouffe, c'est vraiment des
produits qui abîment votre santé sur le
long terme.
Si on en mange beaucoup tout le temps,
si on en mange beaucoup, si on mange, il
y a des gens qui mangent quasiment que
ça.
Pourquoi ? Bah pour plusieurs raisons
déjà posé la question
déjà parce que c'est pas cher donc euh
parce que c'est voilà la malbouffe est
relativement pas cher hein. C'est c'est
c'est c'est logique parce que c'est
souvent des des entre guillemets des
produits industriels transformés de
grandes cultures, de grandes séries de
voilà euh des produits avec peu
d'ingrédients onéreux à l'intérieur des
voilà une qualité plutôt moyenne à
basse. Donc c'est pas cher, c'est
addictif, c'est extrêmement addictif.
On a dit en début. Ouais. Voilà, vous
commencez un paquet de un paquet de de
snacks, de chips, un soda, bon ben vous
pouvez boire euh un grand verre de soda,
voire deux sans sans sans trop y prêter
attention. Euh voilà, des les crèmes
glacées, les confiseries, enfin tout ça
c'est très additif et en plus il y a une
parce que c'est bon, je me fais la
vocale.
Oui oui oui, c'est vrai. Mais c'est
normal, le l'organisme adore le sucre.
Euh il y a quelques milliers d'années,
on était dans la jungle en pagne ou dans
la savane en train d'essayer de chasser.
Puis quand on trouvait on était en
fourrure,
voilà, peut-être, mais quand on trouvait
une ruche avec du miel, c'était c'était
jackpot quoi.
Et euh les les j'ai un ami qui s'appelle
Dan Saladino qui a qui a publié un livre
en anglais qui s'appelle Eating to
Extinction, donc un excellent livre mais
malheureusement pas traduit.
En français, ça veut dire
euh alors difficile à traduire, c'est
manger jusqu'à l'extinction en fait.
Voilà. Donc
manger jusqu'à en crever.
Ouais, si on veut. Mais en fait, il il a
il a il a réfléchi à la différence de
diète entre de donc de régime, pardon,
entre aujourd'hui et les chasseurs
cuueilleurs. Donc il a il a regardé ce
que comment se comportaiit les derniers
chasseurs cuueilleurs qui existent en
Afrique. Et il s'est rendu compte que
leur leur aliments magique, miracle,
leur sucrerie, enfin le truc qui qui
vraiment les fait euh les le leur plaît
le plus, c'est le miel. Et c'est
vraiment lié à notre besoin
finiologique. Le miel, c'est l'énergie
pure, c'est du du sucre. on on l'absorbe
et on et on a un coup de boost tout de
suite. Et la malbouffe, c'est un peu ça.
C'est c'est du sucre, c'est du gras,
c'est de l'énergie, c'est du boost.
L'organisme, il est il est il est dopé.
C'est une drogue.
J'attrape une autre question internet.
Quels sont les pires produits de
malbouffe les plus méconnus en France ?
Alors, les pires, c'est assez
Attention, pas de diffamation, pas de
dénigrement. Non non non mais je citerai
pas de marque mais simplement si on
prend le PNS le plan national nutrition
santé et cetera, donc on prend on prend
un document officiel et cetera, ils vous
disent d'éviter ce qu'il faut éviter, ce
qu'il faut pas éviter, bah il vous
recommande d'éviter ou de réduire la
consommation d'aliments gras, sucré,
donc les sodas, les confiseries. Plus
récemment le le le focus a été mis sur
les charcuteries par rapport au
problèmes de de cancérigène sur nitrate,
nitrite, viande transformée et cetera.
Donc ces produits-là, après votre
question c'était sur les produits
méconnus. Euh il y a il y a plus
vraiment je pense de produits méconnus
dans la malbouffe euh puisque
aujourd'hui bon on sait on sait quels
sont les ennemis. Donc
non pas les ennemis, les les choses
dangereuses si
les produits malsins disons.
Si on en mange trop,
si on en mange trop, si on fait pas de
sport, si on mange pas les cin fruits et
légumes par jour et cetera et cetera.
Les c fruits et légumes par jour. Ouais,
c'est bien, c'est pas bien.
Quand est-ce qu'il faut manger cinq
fruits et légumes par jour ? Bio, pas
bio, avec la peau, sans la peau ? On se
comprend ?
Ouais.
En fait,
il faut il faut des repères simples.
Donc alors c'est vrai que ça a souvent
été moqué parce que c fruits légumes,
c'est c'est simpliste. D'accord. Mais
c'est vrai que quand on veut parler au
plus grand nombre, il faut des messages
clairs et simples. Donc dire cinq fruits
et légumes par jour, c'est en gros cinq
portions. Donc oui, c'est bien ça. Le
message qui dit il faut manger des
fruits frais, des légumes frais, des
produits sains, des produits naturels
riches en vitamines. Ça c'est un bon
message. Euh donc oui, c'est une bonne
chose. Ensuite, il y a des études, alors
je l'ai plus en tête mais j'en ai lu
tellement, il faut dire.
Il y a des études qui disent que si on
consomme ces fruits et légumes
de l'agriculture intensive,
conventionnelle et cetera, des produits
chargés en pesticides, on perd le
bénéfice de consommer ces produitsl.
Donc des fruits et légumes avec des
fibres, avec des vitamines, avec des
minéraux, c'est bien mais bio, c'est
mieux.
Question internet. Comment faites-vous
vos courses ? Quel rayon ? Et on va pas
dire quel magasin, mais quel rayon ?
Les produits frais. les produits frais,
il y a des rayons dans lesquels je passe
jamais. La conserve par exemple, je me
alors je je n'énigre pas la conserve si
des fois j'achète des conserve en boco.
Voilà.
Fo de morue c'est nécessaire.
Oui, le fo de moru j'en achète
effectivement. Ouais, le fo de moru
c'est excellent. Ouais, tout à fait.
Pas très bon pour les océans d'en manger
trou, c'est ça.
Euh, je suis je suis pas un expert du
foie de moru. Par contre, je trouve ça
très bon. C'est au niveau vitamine,
c'est excellent. Donc, je pense que
c'est un bon produit. Je recommande le
foie de Moru. Euh et en plus, j'ai
travaillé pour une entreprise qui était
peut-être le le plus gros le plus gros
fournisseur mondial de foie de morue et
de et de Tarama.
Donc voilà, le foie de moru, c'est
excellent et j'ai oublié le fil de la
Mais il faut pas en manger tous les
jours dans une grande quantité et ainsi
de suite.
Oui, tout à fait. Alors voilà, si où je
fais mes courses, c'était ça la
question. Donc je fais mes courses bah
là où je peux, si je peux en direct, si
je peux local, si je peux chez chez le
producteur parce que j'aime bien
soutenir les gens, j'aime bien savoir à
qui j'ai affaire. J'aime bien discuter,
comprendre ce qu'ils font. Voilà, quand
je peux pas, je vais au supermarché et
je vais au rayon fruits et légumes.
C'est là où je fais moi et mon épouse,
où on fait nos courses.
Mon épouse et moi.
Mon épouse et moi sur Mais c'est surtout
mon épouse en fait.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que parce que
elle connaît mieux, c'est ça ?
Non, parce qu'elle est adorable et puis
elle m'épargne les choses que j'aime pas
faire. Donc voilà,
vous partagez la tâche.
On essae. J'essaie.
Vous êtes lanceur d'alerte.
Comment ça se passe quand on est lanceur
d'alerte ? Alors nous on a vu les
lanceurs d'alerte dans l'informatique,
dans le renseignement, dans le
journalisme, on en a vu plein
mais ils finissent toujours pareil,
c'est-à-dire
dans une fâcheuse posture.
Ils ont eu des problèmes, il y en a qui
ont essayé et c'est vrai c'est c'est vra
ça c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
bon bref je bon pour raconter l'histoire
donc quand j'ai écrit ce livre-là
j'étais habitué à recevoir des menaces
des des courriers d'avocat des des
communiqués pas sympas et cetera, des
insultes des enfin bref des des de la
diffamation enfin tout ce que vous
voulez. J'étais un peu j'étais un peu un
peu blindé et puis j'ai reçu un courrier
cet été quand même qui m'a vraiment
énervé, qui m'a qui m'a qui m'a mis en
colère parce que je je trouvais ça
vraiment injuste et je me suis dit mais
vraiment dans ce pays on peut plus rien
faire, on peut plus rien dire. Et comme
j'avais eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
lanceurs d'alerte comme Yasmine, comme
Maxime Renaï que tu connais qui est
devenu un ami avec qui on a beaucoup on
a beaucoup échangé, beaucoup partagé,
j'ai appelé ces gens-là, je leur dit il
y a un problème de liberté de parole,
d'expression, de démocratie,
d'information et cetera. Ils m'ont tous
dit la même chose. Il m'a dit "Oui, nous
aussi on en a marre, on en peut plus."
Et on a dit "Bah écoute, faisons un
collectif et on va trouver un moyen de
d'améliorer les choses." Donc, on a
lancé un collectif, lanceur d'alerte en
action avec Yasmine, avec Maxime, avec
d'autres et on a décidé de de de
d'attaquer sur le côté juridique. On est
en train de préparer avec un collectif
d'avocat une plainte qu'on déposera à
Bruxelles contre les procédures Bayon,
contre les attaques pour dénigrement.
C'estàd en fait le dénigrement, c'est
devenu la nouvelle arme de destruction
massive des lanceurs d'alerte. Les
industriels disent voilà ta critiqu est
le produit dénigrement on a perdu x % de
vente à cause de toi on va t'attaquer
nous on a l'argent on a les avocat on a
le temps. On va te saigner on va
t'épuiser, on va on va te détruire
socialement. C'est ça leur stratégie
aujourd'hui.
Donc euh des gens comme
c'est un peu normal quand même. Vous
nuisez au business.
C'est pas comme ça qu'on le voit. C'est
enfin moi je suis un industriel, je
viens de l'industrie, j'ai rien contre
l'industrie, je je soutiens l'industrie,
il faut de l'industrie. Donc pour moi
l'industrie je je suis dedans, je il y a
des bons industriels, il y a voilà, on
pourrait leur faire le sketch des
inconnus avec les chasseurs, mais il y a
des bons industriels, il y a des gens
qui qui peuvent bien produire. Donc
faire de la malbouffe, c'est pas une
fatalité. C'est pas une fatalité. On
peut faire de la bonne bouffe
industrielle. Mais quand on doit avoir
un rendement sur son action,
c'est oui, c'est là qui est le problème,
c'est Mais est-ce qu'on doit considérer
que la nourriture c'est un produit comme
un autre ? Est-ce que manger c'est pas
un droit élémentaire de l'être humain ?
Comme respirer, comme avoir une eau
potable. Voilà. Alors aujourd'hui,
tranche de rock fort quand même. Mince,
ça c'est c'est un droit en France. Bah
ça devrait oui, ça devrait chacun
devrait avoir droit à un accès. Ça fait
partie de la sécurité alimentaire,
c'est-à-dire l'accès à l'alimentaire,
une nourriture abordable, une nourriture
disponible, une nourriture de qualité,
une nourriture acceptable
religieusement, socialement et cetera.
Oui, ça devrait être un droit. Euh et
pour pour en revenir sur les lanceurs
d'alerte parce c'est quand même un sujet
qui me tient à cœur et c'est notre
actualité aujourd'hui, on devait faire
une conférence de presse cette semaine
parce que mon bouquin sort, j'avais
accès à des médias, je me suis dit tiens
c'est bien, on va je vais pouvoir aussi
mettre en avant ce problème des lanceurs
d'alerte. Et une des personnes qui
devait participer à la conférence de
presse a reçu une nouvelle menace, était
en panique et a dit non finalement
Christophe, je peux plus venir, c'est
plus possible, parlez pas de moi, ne
parlez pas de mon de de mon cas et
cetera. Donc on a dû reporter par
rapport à ça. Il y a une vraie pression.
Il y a un acharnement sur les lanceurs
d'alerte qui est absolument scandaleux.
Son en train de gagner.
Non non. Au contraire, il y a des gens
comme Maxime et moi, ça les stimule, ça
les énerve. On se dit c'est trop
injuste. Tu je sais pas si tu rappelles
Calimero, enfin ça c'est de mon époque
mais c'est vraiment trop injuste. Et on
agit dans l'intérêt de la collectivité
parce que aujourd'hui c'est grave,
aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui meurent,
il y a des gens qui souffrent à cause de
ça. Donc on a un devoir d'action pour
les autres, pour nos enfants, pour la
société. Et si on fait rien, on est
complice. C'est pas prendre le problème
dans le mauvais sens dans la dans dans
dans l'alimentation. Au lieu au lieu de
se défendre contre les industriels,
pourquoi ne pas essayer d'apprendre aux
gens à manger correctement ? Bah, c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire, c'est-à-dire
j'explique aux gens les les enfin à mon
échelle, je je veux pas tirer la
couverture à moi, mais qu'est-ce que je
peux faire d'autre ? Qu'expliquer, dire
ce que j'ai vu, raconter et j'espérais
moi que les industriels travaillaient
les industriels que les industriels
m'appelleraient bon Christophe, on a
compris machin, est-ce que tu pourrais
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire des choses
ensemble ? Qu'est-ce que tu as des idées
? Parce que tu vois, je pensais que des
gens comme l'Ale, le syndicat des des
industriels, je pensais qu'on pourrait
communiquer, discuter, mettre en place
des actions, des plans de formation, des
faire des choses quoi. Euh je pensais
qu'il y avait des politiques, je
pourrais me faire des choses, tu vois.
Enfin, à Bruxelles. Alors, on me dit
toujours, j'ai beaucoup d'amis dans les
ONG, voilà, j'ai Food Watch, j'ai que
choisir, je sais pas un peu partout. Et
les gens me disent "Ah, on a beaucoup
parlé de toi, ton émission, ton
intervention, ton bouquin, ton machin."
Mais jamais un politique ne m'a appelé
directement. Jamais. On ne m'a parlé.
Jamais.
Et pourquoi ?
Bah, j'en sais rien. Bah je sais pas.
Enfin, les industriels, j'ai compris, ça
les intéresse pas. Ils veulent pas. Pour
eux, plus le statut quo dure, plus ils
font du business, plus ça continue parce
que c'est extrêmement compliqué et et
honéreux de changer leur formulation et
de changer de business model. Pour eux,
c'est quasi impossible. Pour certains,
c'est quasi impossible.
Euh par contre les pol
Pourquoi c'est impossible de changer de
business model pour eux ?
Bah ça je l'ai je je le soupçonnais mais
je l'ai compris. Il y a eu un article
dans le Financial Times, je crois vous
la communauté comme tu dis pourra pourra
vérifier ou une multinationale de
l'agroalimentaire que je citerai pas.
Euh il y a une note interne où les où
les cadres supérieurs disaient bah voilà
nos produits ne passent pas les critères
pour être reconnus comme saint. Voilà,
ils disent en gros 60 % de notre de
notre portfolio, de notre gamme
catalogue
n'est pas saine, n'est pas sain et c'est
ça qui est intéressant et ne pourra
jamais l'être. Malgré les efforts qu'on
fera, une grosse partie de cette
production ne pourra jamais être saine.
Quand vous faites par exemple des une
poudre chocolatée pour petit-déjeuner
qui contient 80 % de sucre, comment vous
la rendez saine ? En en mettant 75 % 70
60 non, c'est toujours trop sucré.
Donc faire une poudre chocolatée saine
pour le cuis déjeuner, ça veut dire
faire du du cacao en poudre pure comme
comme font des marques bien connu qu'ona
pas non plus. Donc
très bonne d'ailleurs.
Bah oui oui
cher aussi.
Non non pas du tout pas du tout.
C'est plus cher au kilo. D'accord. Mais
quand vous achetez un produit à 80 % de
sucre, c'est vachement cher pour du
sucre. Non, c'est plus cher au kilo,
mais par contre la qualité est
infiniment meilleure.
Le bon marché coûte très cher.
Le Non, c'est c'est la malbouffe qui
coûte cher parce que vous surpayez pour
des produits vous surpayez pour du
sucre. Quand vous achetez du du miel
fraudé chinois, vous surpayez pour du
sucre, même si c'est moins cher que du
vrai miel. Et ensuite quand vous achetez
de la malbouffe, c'est c'est c'est votre
organisme qui va qui va qui va en payer
les conséquences. En France, il y a à
peu près 1 million de diabétiques en
devenir qui s'ignorent aujourd'hui avec
la maladie de nche et cetera. Donc ces
gens-là qui croient faire des économies
avec la malbouffe en fait se détruisent
la santé et ils le péront très cher plus
tard.
Donc non, investir sur la malbouffe est
un très très mauvais calcul.
Les fermiers, ils en sont où ? Est-ce
que vous avez rencontré des fermiers,
des producteurs ?
Oui, j'en ai rencontré dans la dans la
famille de mon épouse, c'était quasiment
tous des fermiers. Il en reste plus un
seul. En une génération, ça a été
complètement éradiqué.
Donc donc voilà. Non, le le monde
agricole, bon, on sait on sait où il en
est. On sait que comme mais en fait
comme dans l'industrie, on a voulu
rationaliser. Il y avait trop de PME, il
a fallu concentrer. Il y avait trop de
supermarchés, on a concentré. Il y avait
trop d'exploitation agricole, on a
concentré. Mais ça c'est la logique
mercantile bruxellienne, bruxelloise ou
voilà une
question sur les les aliments végan ou
styles végan.
Ouais.
C'est bien, c'est pas bien, c'est bon,
c'est ça dépend. Toujours pareil, il
faut il faut faire il faut faire la part
des choses. C'est rarement ou tout noir
ou tout blanc. Et végan ça veut dire je
crois pas de viande. Donc si on mange
des haric sec, des produits naturels,
aucun problème. C'est parfait.
Van, ça veut dire sans animaux morts.
C'est ça,
je crois. Oui, personnellement, je suis
pas de cette religion là, mais
c'est pas une religion.
Bon ben, je suis Oui, peut-être, je sais
pas, de ce mouvement, de ce courant, de
cette idéologie, de je sais pas comment
il faut il faut le décrire.
Personnellement, je suis je suis pas fan
parce que je pense que pour ne pas avoir
de carence, enfin bon, vitamine B12, on
en parle souvent, ça enfin ça se trouve
dans les produits d'origine animaux.
Donc je pense que structurellement, on
est fait pour consommer au moins un peu
de produits animaux.
Donc on est omnivore, c'est notre
nature. Enfin, c'est ce que c'est ce que
moi je pense. Après, je respecte tout le
monde. Si les gens qui veulent être
végan ben très très bien pour eux, aux
conditions de se supplémenter pour pas
avoir de soucis de santé. Euh mais
végan, végétarien, c'est voilà, c'est
bien. Oui, des produits végétaux, c'est
bien à condition de pas tomber dans
l'extrême des produits ultra
transformés. Et c'est là que que pour
moi est le danger, c'est-à-dire que les
produits ultra transformés, c'est quasi
synonyme de malbouffe
parce que c'est c'est des produits qui
sont texturés, des produits qui ont pas
de vitamines, qui ont pas de fibr, qui
ont pas de minéraux, c'est des produits
aromatisés, c'est des produits qui
apportent pas de satiété, enfin c'est
des produits non naturels.
Alors, il faut aussi voir les critères
écologiques. C'est vrai que si on
compare l'élevage avec la consommation
en eau, la consommation d'espace et
cetera, les produits végan ont peut-être
une empreinte carbone moindre. Et
encore, ça se discute parce que quand
vous avez des pâturages par exemple, les
pâturages, ils peuvent pas être
cultivés. Donc si vous avez des
pâturages, des alpages par exemple à
part de l'élevage, vous pouvez pas en
faire grand-chose d'autre. Si demain il
y a plus de vaches ou plus de moutons
pour brouter les alpages, c'est de la
terre perdue. Donc c'est comme toujours,
c'est il c'est ou non ou tout noir ou
tout blanc. Euh il faut il faut être
intelligent, il faut accepter un petit
peu toutes les positions et essayer de
trouver des positions de compromis là où
voir où c'est intelligent de faire les
choses bien.
Question internet, [raclement de gorge]
c'est peut-être pas votre domaine.
Est-ce que les accords alimentaires avec
le Canada, l'Amérique du Sud ne va ne
vont pas tuer l'agriculture française et
mettre mal la sécurité alimentaire de la
France ? Mettre à mal la sécurité
alimentaire de la France de l'Europe ?
La sécurité alimentaire. Alors si on si
on prend le le terme sécurité
alimentaire sans sustricto, il y a pas
de risque. C'est-à-dire que la France
est un pays riche. Si si on si on a
besoin de de nourriture, on importe.
Moi, j'ai vécu à Singapour de nombreuses
années. Singapour ne produit quasiment
rien en nourriture. Ils ont mis des
accords en place des accords de de
fourniture avec la Malaisie, avec
l'Australie, avec la Chine. Donc, ils
importent peut-être 80 % de la
nourriture mais ils ont la sécurité
alimentaire. Ils ont varié leurs
approvisionnements, ils ont sécurisé
leur contrat et c'est un pays riche donc
ils peuvent se payer la nourriture,
j'allais dire quel que soit son prix.
Euh la France, même chose, on pourra
toujours, je enfin j'espère que ça va
continuer enfin qu'on va pas
s'approuvrir euh trop rapidement malgré
la direction qui est prise aujourd'hui
et je pense qu'on pourra quand même se
payer la nourriture sur les marchés
mondiaux. Ceci dit,
si l'euro s'effondre,
ça risque d'être compliqué, hein.
Oui, mais bon, je pense que de toute
façon, des pays comme le Canada qui sont
largement excédentaires pour plein de
produits baisseront leurs prix, ils
seront ils sauront être abordables. Il
faut qu'ils vendent ces produits. Les
États-Unis pareil, il faut qu'ils
vendent leurs produits puisque ils
produisent plus que nécessaire pour leur
pour leur population. Donc, ils
exporteront, ils se mettront au prix de
marché.
Est-ce que les industriels modélisent en
fait le changement climatique dans leur
production ? Vous prenez l'exemple du
Canada. Tu prends l'exemple du Canada.
Là, ils ont eu un petit problème de
sécheresse avec le sirop d'érable.
Heureusement qu'ils avaient des gros
stocks, mais là leur stock commençait à
à faire grisimine.
Est-ce que les industriels sont
tellement nés dans le guidon, le pied au
plancher pour marger, respecter,
essayer de survivre pour certains ?
Est-ce que le réchauffement climatique,
il l'anticipe dans leur stratégie par
exemple ? Oui. Oui. Ouais. Tout à fait.
Bah pour ce qui est des achats et les
approvisionnements, c'est c'est mon
métier depuis très depuis très
longtemps. Donc ma responsabilité, c'est
de sécuriser les approvisionnement,
d'assurer la sécurité de l'entreprise,
tu vas dire, en terme
d'approvisionnement.
Un peu comme les lieux de musque avec le
lithium.
Oui, probablement. Probablement. Donc
voilà, si jamais demain l'usine est en
rupture parce que j'aurais pas anticipé,
parce que j'aurais pas prévu et cetera,
clairement je passerai un sal quart
d'heure et je resterai pas en poste
cement certainement très longtemps. Donc
ma responsabilité c'est d'essayer de
prévoir les choses et de sécuriser mes
approvisionnements. Quelquefois c'est
pas simple mais je dois convaincre en
interne de devoir payer un peu plus cher
un produit pour pouvoir avoir un autre
fournisseur, une autre source, un autre
pays quand c'est possible. C'est pas
toujours possible.
Comment tu fais pour anticiper ? Est-ce
que tu as une veille ? Est-ce que tu as
des gens sur place ?
Il y a il y a aussi des cabinets de
conseil dont c'est le métier. Vous avez
des gens comme Dan anden Brad Street par
exemple, des cabinets de conseil, des
cabinets de prospective qui vendent de
l'information économique et qui vous
disent voilà de gestion des risques.
Alors c'est tout risque, ça peut être
risque politique de logistique, risque
sanitaire comme le Covid par exemple. Et
en en temps réel, vous avez des alertes
sur une explosion à un endroit, sur une
révolte à un autre, sur un port qui est
congestionné. Enfin, il y a vous ça vous
coûte de l'argent mais ça vous importe
de l'intelligence économique. Donc
voilà, on a ce genre d'outil. Euh
comment tu fais ta prospective ? Est-ce
que tu écoutes la prospective des autres
parce que tu es abonné à Pierre Pjack ?
Il y a ça effectivement, mais surtout
j'entretiens un contact permanent avec
mes fournisseurs
euh avec mes concurrents également.
C'est-à-dire que on peut être en
concurrence à la vente mais à l'achat,
on a quand même un peu tous le même
intérêt. Donc il faut quand même que le
on arrive tous un peu à trouver nos
produits. Donc
et peut-être aussi à manipuler les prix.
Alors
[grognement] si vous êtes tous cul et
chemise à l'achat, vous pouvez mettre la
pression sur un producteur. C'est ça.
Non non non non.
jusqu'à aujourd'hui, on n' jamais eu la
puissance nécessaire pour arriver à ça.
En règle générale,
recherché,
non, même pas. Même pas parce que on a
on n jamais été suffisamment gros et
puissant pour pouvoir peser vis-à-vis
des fournisseurs. Aujourd'hui, on a
plutôt des fournisseurs trop puissants.
Par exemple, les Chinois, enfin, il y a
beaucoup de produits qui ne se trouvent
aujourd'hui plus qu'en Chine.
Comment ? Bah les antibiotiques
typiquement tu veux
automatique. [rires]
Ah bah c'est automatiquement en Chine.
Si tu veux acheter l'amoxycilline du
fluorphéicol chlore thétracique ligne du
alkinol c'est qu'en Chine ou quasiment
qu'en Chine tu peut-être un fournisseur
en Inde et puis c'est tout. Donc ces
produits-là se trouvent en Chine. Les
fournisseurs chinois, ils sont en
général 4 5 6 même des fois tu as des
marchés où il y a que deux ou trois
fournisseur.
Donc ces gens-là mais et même c'est
assez drôle parce que des fois par
exemple pour l'amoxicyine typiquement
quand on en discute avec les vendeurs,
ils ont dit bah voilà le prix
aujourd'hui il est à 32. Ah on considère
que c'est trop bas. Il y a eu une
réunion la dernière réunion de la du
CPHI, c'est la la réunion des des des
c'est le c'est le salon de la pharmacie.
On s'est réuni, on a trouvé que le bon
prix c'était 36. Donc maintenant c'est
36 pour tout le monde. Et effectivement,
on t'appelle tous les fournisseurs,
c'est 36. Ça va durer quelques semaines
en général parce qu'après il y en a
toujours un qui a envie de vendre plus
que les autres et puis qui va dire "Ah
oui mais à toi comme tu es un ami
machin, je te le fais à 35" et là pou ça
pas r mais les accords de prix sont
classiques en Chine. Très classique.
Mais personne ne dit jamais rien parce
que de toute façon avec les Chinois on
dit jamais rien.
Pourquoi on dit jamais rien ? parce que
les industriels sont pas là pour faire
de la politique ou se lancer dans des
procédures. Notre métier, c'est pas de
faire des procédures qu'on s'est perdu
d'avance qui vont coûter cher et cetera.
Notre métier, c'est de produire et
livrer nos clients. Donc on sait que il
y a des accords qui sont illégaux he
puisque la Chine fait partie de l'OMC
que il y a du dumping. On sait que voilà
mais c'est pas à l'industriel de régler
ce genre de problème, c'est aux
politiques. Les politiques le font pas.
Pourquoi ils le font pas ? C'est eux
qu'il faut poser la question.
Question internet. Que pensent-il du
vrac ? Hm hm.
Le vrac, le vrac le vrac. Oui, pourquoi
pas ? Je suis pas certain que ce soit
une solution. Voilà, on vois, je suis
plutôt pour réduire de beaucoup les
emballages, c'est-à-dire avoir des
emballages adaptés, avoir peut-être des
plus gros conditionnements. Toi, tu
parlais du du
de la shrink flation, c'est ça ? Donc la
la réduction de de taille pour les Moi,
je suis pour des tablettes de chocolat à
200 g, par exemple.
Elles sont déjà à 200 g les tablettes
ou maintenant tu vas en supermarché, tu
vas en trouver à 80 g.
Euh les pots de yaourt maintenant tu
peux en trouver à moins de 100 g. Euh
voilà le le kilo de sucre avant bah qui
était vendu en kilo, maintenant tu peux
en avoir à 750 g, voire moins. Donc si
déjà on avait des contenants un petit
peu plus gros, ça permettrait d'avoir
moins d'emballage. Euh ensuite
l'emballage a quand même une fonction,
c'est-à-dire il protège le produit, il
évite de les contamination.
Donc l'emballage a quand même une puis
aussi l'information. C'estàd que sur
l'emballage vous avez la DLC, vous avez
des des informations quand même pour le
consommateur. C'est date limite de
consommation.
Exactement.
Mais là le vra par exemple s'il y a un
étalage pour aller acheter en gros le
les cérales du matin ou vos petits
poids.
Oui, c'est bien. C'est Oui, après on a
son emballage et qu'on revient avec.
Oui, c'est bien. Oui. Oui, pourquoi pas
? Oui. Ou la consigne peut-être. Par
exemple, en Autriche, il y a un système
de consigne qui existe pour certains
produits liquides, type les boissons,
type les yaourts par exemple. Quand
c'est vendu en pet vert, souvent vous
avez une consigne. Donc c'est une chose
qui qui est mise en place. Est-ce
qu'écologiquement c'est valable ? Je je
là je manque de je manque de données.
Comment ça va en Autriche ? Les prix ont
augmenté, les salaires sont Ouais.
L'énergie a explosé
de combien
la facture à la maison elle a augmenté
de combien ? Il y a un bouclier
tarifaire. Il y a pas de bouclier
tarifaire.
Alors alors c'est difficile à dire parce
qu'on paye en avance sur une il y a une
bon moi ma facture a doublé là tout
récemment. Mon épouse me l'a dit il y a
quelques jours au téléphone, donc la
facture a doublé. Mais c'est pas évident
que c'est la somme qu'on va payer
puisque c'est une avance. Donc peut-être
que je
ce sera peut-être plus cher.
Sera peut-être plus cher, sera peut-être
un peu moins cher, mais mais quoi qu'il
en soit, ça a beaucoup beaucoup augmenté
et oui, ça aura des répercussions et
puis j'imagine que bah les les gens vont
demander les augmentations de salaires
pour compenser et puis voilà, c'est la
porte ouverte à l'inflation quoi.
Dans les supermarchés, ça augmenté aussi
en Autriche.
Oui, énormément. Oui. Ouais. surtout les
produits les moins chers
du genre.
La farine par exemple, la farine est
passée alors la farine bio que nous on
achetait là où on l'achetait de 1 €
c'est passé 1,50 € donc ça a pris plus
50 %.
L'alimentation animale aussi augmente ?
Euh l'alimentation animale augmente.
Oui, oui, oui, oui. Alors, nous, on est
plutôt fournisseur de de d'additifs pour
l'alimentation animale, mais d'additif
dans le bon sens du terme, c'est-à-dire
que de produits qu'on ajoute mais qui
sont naturels.
Du genre
du genre des huiles essentielles, du
genre des vitamines.
Les huiles essentielles, c'est pas un
petit peu surfait ?
Non, parce que ça a quand même une
efficacité.
Prouvé par qui ?
Comment ?
Prouvé par qui ? Non non, pas des
études. Des études. Nous, on a des
études, on a un centre de
d'expérimentation sur les animaux. Donc,
on leur fait tester nos produits, on
voit comment ils se comporte.
L'expérimentation animale de de quel
type vous mettez ?
Le type, on met nos produits dans les
aliments pour voir comment ils se
comportent. On fait des vaccins aussi,
des vaccins pour les animaux. Donc, on
teste les produits. Euh donc voilà. Non,
non, non, les les huiles essentielles
sont efficaces, moins efficaces qu'un
antibiotique, c'est certain. Euh mais il
y a une efficacité.
Ensuite, il faut savoir que les
antibiotiques étaient beaucoup utilisés.
Je dis étais,
je pourrais je pourrais parler au
présent aussi. Enfin bon, il y a des
pays où c'est encore massivement
utilisé. Des pays comme le Chili par
exemple consomme toujours 1000 tonnes
par an de fleur phénicole pour le
saumon. C'est un antibiotique qui est
utilisé pour le saumon d'élevage. Ils
produisent chaque année dans les 700000
tonnes de saumon d'élevage au Chili. Et
pour ces 700000 tonnes, ils consoment à
peu près 1000 tonnes
[raclement de gorge] de fleur phénico.
Voilà. Donc ça ça peut pas être pour
soigner des poissons malades. C'est
mélangé à l'alimentation et c'est un
promoteur de croissance. Ce qu'on
appelle un promoteur de croissance parce
que alors les mécanismes on les connaît
pas exactement mais si tu donnes dans
l'alimentation régulière des animaux un
antibiotique,
il va grossir plus vite, il va prendre
du poids plus rapidement.
Et ce cette ces ces ces ces grosses
promoteurs, ces promoteurs de croissance
ont un gros gros problème pour la
multirésistance des bactéries. À force
de gaver les animaux avec des
antibiotiques, les les bactéries
deviennent multirésistantes et ça c'est
un gros problème. Donc de plus en plus
de de molécules sont interdites. Par
exemple, le le le Brésil a interdit je
crois la la CTC il y a pas longtemps. Là
c'est quoi la CTC ? la chlore
thétracycline, le le CTCHC, le le la
chlore euh l'hydrochloride de chlore
tétracycline. Donc c'est une molécule
qui a été je crois interdite au Brésil
tout récemment
justement pour éviter ces problèmes de
résistance. Et il y a aussi des
antibiotiques qui étaient autorisés
avant pour les les animaux qui
maintenant sont réservés aux humains.
Donc c'est un problème qui commence à
être pris à être pris au sérieux par les
autorités. Heureusement.
Question internet. [grognement] J'en
attrape une.
L'agroécologie, vous connaissez ? Euh,
pas bien, pas bien, pas bien. Mais
j'aime bien l'agro et j'aime bien
l'écologie. Donc, donc je pense que
c'est un truc valable, mais bon, je suis
pas un expert malheureusement.
Vous mangez beaucoup de viande ?
Pas beaucoup. Non, non, non. Même assez
peu en réalité. Non, non, très peu. Mais
par contre, on essaie de se faire
plaisir quand on en prend. Alors, c'est
forcément de la bio.
Bah, sauf quand je suis en déplacement
et que je vais au resto, des fois c'est
pas toujours possible. Mais à ce qu'on
achète nous pour notre alimentation,
c'est forcément de la viande bio. Assez
cher, mais on en mange peu.
Combien au kilos ?
Alors, ça dépend si c'est de la
volaille, ça dépend si c'est du bœuf.
Mais alors on va dans une boutique bio,
quand on prend du foie, c'est super
cher. Doit être 40 ou 50 € du kilo.
Enfin, c'est vraiment des prix très
élevés. La volaille, c'est moins que ça.
Alors, je sais pas, peut-être 20 €. Ma
femme serait plus précise là-dessus,
mais c'est les ordres d'idées quoi.
Les insectes,
h
c'est bien, c'est pas bien.
Ça je connais bien. Ça je connais bien.
Les insectes, c'est très bien. Et
insectes, c'est vraiment
Vous produisez des insectes aussi, vous
avez des produisse parce que j'ai j'ai
des j'ai des très bons amis, très
proches qui qui ont monté une la plus
grosse start-up en France des insectes.
C'est une très belle réussite. Je suis
ami avec le le fond d'investissement qui
les a aidé à se lancer. J'ai fait avec
eux une tournée en Asie pour les
présenter à des à des clients qu'on
avait donc parce que ils avaient des des
véléités de de vendre ce produit en
Asie. Et en fait pour moi, c'est une
très très bonne solution pour éviter la
surpêche.
C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui, il y a
beaucoup de surpêche pour l'aquaculture.
Donc notamment les crevettes. Donc
toutes les crevettes sont nourries avec
de la farine de poisson. Euh les
saumons, les enfin tous les poissons
d'élevage sont nourris à base de farine
de poisson. C'est pas plus mal. Non
non mais bon c'est qu'à un moment donné
à force de surpêcher les océances vides,
la farine de poisson, ces petits
poissons qu'on pêche au large du Chili,
les enchois et cetera ou au large de la
Thaïlande, c'est à la base de la chaîne
alimentaire. C'estàdire que les gros
poissons se nourissent de petits
poissons. Bah oui, c'est naturel.
Voilà.
Sauf que comme on a des productions
extraordinaires, il faut des
il faut les chasser pour eux du
Exactement. Donc il y a de la surpêche
et utiliser ces protéines, ces nouvelles
sources de protéines pour nourrir les
poissons, l'aquaculture et cetera, c'est
une très bonne solution.
Ouais.
Et pour l'homme ? Non, pour l'homme, il
y a pas d'intérêt. Non, non, pour
l'homme, il y a pas d'intérêt. Alors,
c'est oui, c'est rigolo d'en parler, ça
fait ça fait des articles sympas, mais
pour l'homme, non, il y a pas d'intérêt.
Enfin, aujourd'hui, on peut se nourrir
avec euh avec de des produits
classiques.
Vous trouvez qu'il y a pas d'intérêt ?
Enfin, il y a il y a des pays où on en
consomme. Moi, quand je suis allé en
Chine, à chaque fois, les les
fournisseurs me faisaient la blague de
me faire un plat d'insectes. Alors, j'ai
eu j'ai eu mangé de la larve d'abeille,
j'ai eu mangé du scolopandre du un peu
tout ça. Quand j'étais en Thaïlande, on
m'a fait manger de la salade d'œuf de
fourmis, de je sais pas. Oui, ça se
consomme là où c'est traditionnel. Vous
allez au Laos, pareil, vous bordez des
routes, on vous on vous sert des des des
des plats de de grillon. Enfin, oui, ça
se consomme. C'est voilà. Mais
quel goût ça ?
Un goût d'huile. Un goû c'est c'est de
la friture en général, donc c'est très
huileux. Euh la larve d'abeille, c'est
sûrement ce que j'ai mangé de mieux
parce que c'était assez sucré, c'était
moelleux, c'était pas mauvais. Euh le le
le le moins bon, c'était les espèces de
scolocor parce qu'il y avait une
carapace, ça croustillait, c'était
vraiment pas terrible. Mais bon, ça vaut
pas une bonne viande ou un bon plat
préparé ou des lasagnes.
Vous n'aimiez pas le scolopant ?
Non, je pas scolop mais c'était un genre
de 1000 pattes quoi.
Il avait ses pattes encore ou pas ?
Ouais, il y avait ses pattes. Ses
pattes, il était tout noir et puis
voilà. Bon,
question internet. Que pensent-t-il
d'acheter des produits bruts et de
comparer que le prix au kilo ?
Je comprends pas la question. Bah quand
vous allez dans un supermarché au lieu
de regarder le prix
h
qui est affiché en gros faut regarder le
petit prix en bas à droite qui est
marqué
Ah mais je regarde toujours le prix au
kilo. Oui
oui ou oui tout à fait. Oui oui c'est ce
que je fais. Je regarde le prix au kilo.
Le prix du produit m'intéresse pas.
C'est le prix au kilo qui m'intéresse.
C'estd il faut comparer des choses sur
une base comparable.
Donc n'achetez que des produits bruts et
comparer que le prix au kilo.
Oui tout à fait. Et pareil quand vous
achetez un produit pas brut il faut
regarder le le même référentiel.
C'est-à-dire que par exemple la valeur
énergétique ou calorique, il faut
regarder soit en kiljoule, soit en
kilocalories, soit en portion, soit en
100 g. Donc il faut comparer des choses
comparable toujours.
Question internet qui est d'ailleurs
peut-être un peu utopiste mais
on va la poser quand même. J'ai une
question, une question de Sami, j'ai une
question. Est-il possible d'œer pour un
label géré par des spécialistes
militants contre la mauvaise bouffe, la
mauvaise alimentation et les mauvaises
pratiques industrielles financées par
les dons de sportifs ? et des personnes
financièrement privilégiées
ou là c'est oui enfin c'est une question
qu'on m'a souvent posé. On m'a dit "Mais
pourquoi tu fais pas ton label et cetera
?" Alors je me suis dit déjà c'est
extrêmement difficile de se mettre
d'accord sur des critères de qualité. La
qualité pour moi c'est pas forcément la
même que la qualité pour toi. Quels sont
les critères qui pour toi sont
importants ? Est-ce que c'est l'éthique
? Est-ce que c'est la qualité comment la
juste rétribution ?
Oui. Bah la juste rétribution. Donc
après donc c'est très difficile de
définir de de quelle qualité on parle
euh sanitaire, écologique,
environnemental et si tu veux tout
couvrir, ça devient quand même
compliqué. Ensuite, il y a déjà beaucoup
de label. J'allais dire même beaucoup
trop de label. Moi je dans mon bouquin
sur le bio par exemple, je parlais de
mon chocolat. J'achète du chocolat qui
est super bon, qui est excellent, qui
est bio et cetera. Mais sur ma tablette,
j'ai 12 labels entre le recycler, le
label bio, l'équitable, le le biourcé,
le carton recyclé, le made in France.
Enfin bon bref, à un moment donné, ça
devient ridicule d'avoir autant de label
et ils sont créés des nouveaux tous les
jours, tout le temps. Donc avoir le un
petit peu comme dans le Seigneur des
Anneaux, le le label qui les contrôle
tous, oui, c'est une c'est une belle
idée mais techniquement c'est compliqué
et moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à
militer pour moins de label. Tu vois, il
y a le label rouge, il y a le bio, les
AOC, les AOP, les les faux labels, les
produits élus, tu sais, produits saveur
de l'année, enfin par
un faux, c'est pas un faux label
ça ça s'achète. Enfin, nous on en
achetait c'était le marketing qui
s'occupait de ça.
Donc c'est des marques privées. Oui.
Enfin voilà, je dis ça s'achète. Il faut
être élu. Enfin quand tu es
faut être élu forcément
quand il y a qu'une catégorie puis qu'un
compétiteur, tu es assez facilement élu
quoi. Donc donc voilà, il faut il
c'est dur ce que vous venez de dire là
quand même hein.
Non mais c'est Oui. Enfin oui, je enfin
on les a pratiqué. Voilà quand tu fais
un produit qui est pas une nouveauté qui
comme par hasard il est élu puis que
dans la catégorie il y a deux produits.
Bon
donc voilà. Non, il y a des labels qui
ont aucune valeur. Il y a des labels
intéressants, mais il y a des labels.
Tu trouves tu trouves qu'il y a pas de
valeur ?
Oui. Non, mais ce que je dis, c'est mon
opinion. Voilà. Disclaimer, c'est ce que
je dis n'engage que moi et c'est une
opinion voilà donc basée sur mon
expérience et ce que est-ce que je crois
savoir ?
Question internet.
Existe-t-il toujours une production
scientifique entre guillemets
sponsorisée
par l'industrie agroalimentaire visant à
minorer les effets de la malbouffe ? une
idée du pourcentage du chiffre
d'affaires consacré ?
Ah, c'est très difficile. C'est très
difficile. Alors, déjà la première
réponse est oui. On investit toujours
beaucoup d'argent dans les, on va dire,
les influenceurs ou voilà ceux qui ceux
qui peuvent nous aider. Donc ça peut
être les scientifiques, ça peut être les
médias, c'est bien sûr les lobbyes. Euh
tout type d'influenceurs, donc tous ceux
qui peuvent porter la bonne parole.
C'est-à-dire aller dans l'autre sens.
Si c'est une étude scientifique qui est
correcte, c'est bon.
Ça dépend.
On finance quand je dis on je dis
l'industrie dans son ensemble finance
énormément d'études parce que les
chercheurs ont besoin de moyens pour
travailler et un chercheur si il a pas
d'études à à faire il publie pas. S'il
publie pas, sa carrière progresse pas.
C'est bien ça qu'il faut comprendre.
Donc ça pour résumer, le chercheur a
besoin d'argent pour faire des études et
faire avancer sa carrière. Il faut dire
merci au industriel.
Voilà, donc les industriels ont de
l'argent et besoin d'influencer. Donc
entre nous qui enfin entre l'industriel
qui a de l'argent et besoin d'influencer
et et certains parce qu'il y a quand
même des gens très éthiques et honnêtes,
il faut pas il faut pas généraliser et
certains chercheurs qui veulent faire
avancer leur carrière et qui sont à la
recherche de financement. Bon ben
souvent il y a des accords qui se font.
Euh ensuite, quand on finance une étude,
on a quand même un droit de regard et il
faut savoir
pourquoi vous avez un droit de regard
pourquoi tu as un droit de regard ?
Parce qu'on paye. Quand tu payes quelque
chose, normalement tu as droit de bah de
de donner ton avis.
Si tu ne vas pas dans tes intérêts, tu
sors pas l'étude.
C'est là où je voulais en venir. C'est
là où je voulais en venir.
C'est ma question. Oui, c'est ça. Et
alors, il y a eu une étude très
intéressante. Alors, je sais, je crois
que j'en que je la cite. Alors, faudrait
retrouver les a il y a plusieurs études
sur ça qui dit en gros que euh dans les
études financées par l'industrie, elles
sont en faveur de l'industrie dans je
sais plus dans peut-être 80 % des cas.
Alors que les études purement
indépendantes, le ratio est inversé
parce que il y a plusieurs choses. Soit
on publiera pas des études qui vont pas
dans le bon sens premièrement ou alors
on financera des études sur un critère
qu'on sait nous être favorable. Par
exemple, par exemple, c'est facile, tu
es fabricant de jus d'orange, d'accord ?
Tu sais que dans le jus d'orange, il y a
de la vitamine C. Donc tu vas trouver un
gars, tu vas dire "Bah voilà, est-ce que
tu peux me faire une étude sur la
vitamine C et dire que peut-être la
vitamine C c'est bon pour le le le
cerveau, pour la réflexion, pour on est
de meilleure humeur, enfin voilà,
trouver quelque chose de positif par
rapport à la vitamine C." Le chercheur
va dire "Ah oui, la vitamine C
intéressant." Donc il va travailler,
faire une étude sur la vitamine C
éventuellement de toute bonne foi. Il va
publier la vitamine C, je sais pas moi,
aide à l'érection du matin par exemple.
Ça peut intéresser des gens.
l'industriel va récupérer l'étude et il
va dire voilà
c'est pour ça
moi fabriquant deux jus d'orange riche
en vitamine C j'aide à l'érection du
matin. Voilà ça se passe comme ça.
C'est magnifique.
Oui c'est ça.
Mais est-ce que ça aide à l'érection du
matin ?
Non je sais pas c'était un exemple pour
faire pour pour faire rire mais il y a
des études. C'est exactement ça. Et si
j'ai pris l'exemple du jus d'orange vous
la retrouverez peut-être. C'est pas
c'est pasin
les principes de précaution sanitaire.
Ouais.
Est-ce que ça décime l'agriculture
française ? La vie culture la vie
culture française ? Est-ce que tu as les
infos ? Pas d'infos ? Est-ce que c'est
vrai ? C'est pas vrai ?
Non. Ce qui décime l'industrie française
c'est c'est les charges, c'est les
impôts, c'est les taxes. C'est pas du
tout les règlements. Les règlements sont
européens aujourd'hui. En France, on a
les mêmes règlements que qu'ailleurs.
Donc donc non, c'est pas c'est pas la
surréglementation. Alors, il est
possible qu'en France, on la fasse
appliquer avec plus de rigueur
qu'ailleurs. C'est possible, c'est
probable. Euh mais non, si on n'est pas
compétitif en France, c'est parce que
les charges sont trop élevées.
Quand je dis charge, je dis charge plus
taxe, enfin toutes les prélèvements
obligatoires.
Des cotisations.
Oui, cotisation, charge et autres.
Redistribution, imposition,
taxes et cetera.
Question internet. Quel est selon vous
le plus gros problème de santé publique
lié à l'alimentation ? pesticide pour
interrogation, trop gras, virgule sucré
interrogation.
Aujourd'hui, ça reste encore le
déséquilibre nutritionnel d'après les
données que nous avons aujourd'hui. Les
gros problèmes et les gros problèmes à
venir, ça va être diabète et diabète de
type 2. Donc on soupçonne très fortement
le fructose. Donc le fructose, c'est un
vrai problème. C'est
presque une suspicion.
C'est difficile de mettre en cause un
produit particulier parce que quand vous
mangez, vous mangez pas que du fructose.
Tu vois quand on fait un test sur des
animaux, on peut leur donner ou des
souris, tu vois. On peut leur donner à
manger que du fructose et voir ce que ça
fait. Un humain. Non, on peut pas lui
dire "Tu mangeras que du fructose
pendant 6 mois." Donc c'est très
difficile de se dire quand tu as des
problèmes de alimentaires, par exemple,
quel est l'aliment ou le groupe
d'aliments qui cause ces problèmes ?
Est-ce que c'est le fructose ? Est-ce
que c'est d'autres choses ? Est-ce que
c'est le fructose associé à autre chose
? Et cetera. Mais on sait quand même que
plus on consomme de fructose notamment
et de sucre, plus on a de chances
d'avoir des diabètes de type 2 et de la
nage par exemple. Donc la la c'est la
c'est la stéatose hépatique
nonalcoolique.
La cyrose,
c'est une cyrose qui est pas liée à
l'alcool. Et c'est drôle parce que c'est
drôle,
c'est drôle,
c'est comment dire ? Non drôle, il faut
il faut oublier. C'est c'est surprenant
quand on sait que en France la
consommation d'alcool a été divisée par
2 en 50 ans et que les sirros ont été
ont explosé, ont été multiplié par deux
ou trois.
Les chiffres viennent d'où ? de
Nashche la maladie de la balbouffe du
docteur Dominique Lan un livre que je
recommande fortement. La recommandation
de livre c'est après toi qui me pose la
question.
Question internet. Des études sont-elles
en cours pour établir un rapport entre
nourriture industrielle et Alzheimer ?
C'est fort possible. Alors, il faut
savoir que en France et ça été mis en
place, je crois, alors c'est à vérifier
mais je crois par Roseline Bachelot
qui a mis en place alors pas seul mais
bon le la cororte Nutrinette santé
Nutrinette
la Nutrinette santé je crois le terme
exact et en fait c'est des un suivi sur
une très longue période d'une population
importante des habitudes de consommation
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif
c'était d'atteindre 500000 personnes et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est à plus de
200000 personnes qu'on suit sur des
années et on voit comment cette
population enfin ce qu'elle mange et
comment sa santé évolue. Et donc il y a
déjà eu de très bons résultats où où on
s'est aperçu que ben si on consommait 10
% de plus de mal de nourriture ultra
transformée, on avait 10 % de cancer en
plus. Donc cette cette étude Nutrin de
santé qui est française qui est une très
belle initiative qui donne des résultats
donc c'est géré par l'INCERM, le KNAM,
le Paris 13, enfin il y a tout un
ensemble de de d'organismes
scientifiques qui suivent ça. Donc c'est
vraiment des traitements de de données à
grosse échelle donnent de bons résultats
et je pense qu'effectivement ils
pourront avoir des données suffisantes
sur ce type de maladie Alzheimer et
autres. Que pens-il du circuit court et
qui se passe des intermédiaires ainsi
que la possibilité des villes
autosuffisantes ? Alors, c'est très bien
le circuit court. Donc, je pense que si
on est en direct, si on évite les
intermédiaires, ça permet de mieux
rémunérer les producteurs. Donc, c'est
très bien. Si les gens peuvent mieux
vivre de leur travail, c'est parfait.
Euh, les villes autosuffisantes, ça me
paraît ça me paraît compliqué.
Alors nous on avait beaucoup investi
notamment à Singapour dans le vertical
farming le la
les fermes vertical.
Voilà c'est ça parce que là-bas le en
gros si vous investissez dans une ferme
verticale le gouvernement vous en
rembourse la moitié ou un truc comme ça.
Donc il y a vraiment une une grosse
incitation dans ce type d'industrie
parce que comme je disais Singapour est
pas autosuffisant loin de là et ils ont
il y a plus de ferme à Singapour. Il y a
une seule ferme et je crois que c'est
des chèvres. Ils font un peu de chèvre.
C'est voilà, c'est juste pour le
folklore. Ils ont plus de porc, ils ont
un petit peu de pesticulture mais c'est
tout. Et donc ils sont ils font des œufs
également mais c'est tout. Voilà, ils
ont pas de vaches, pas de pas de cochon,
pas de pas de bassecour. Et donc il ils
promeut ils promeuvent le l'agriculture
verticale, la biotechnologie, les
viandes, les nouvelles types de les
zersat de viande, voilà les je sais pas
comment les qualifier tous ces produits
un petit peu un petit peu de de génie
génétique de de cellules souches et
cetera de manière à être beaucoup plus
autosuffisant.
Euh
c'est personnellement c'est pas ma
conception de la bonne nourriture,
c'estàdire que des salades qui poussent
dans des container
éclairés par de la lumière artificielle
qui sont hors sol, qui sont dans une
solution hydroponique,
ça me fait pas rêver. Après pour des
pays comme Singapour, pour être plus
indépendant, je comprends en France, on
a beaucoup de terres agricoles, on a du
terroir, on a du savoir-faire,
on a des sols épuisés, on a des sols
contaminés. sol, ça peut on peut bien
les traiter, on peut on peut les voilà,
on peut les régénérer, on peut voilà, on
peut on peut revenir en arrière.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des fermes
chinoises à port là qui font 15 20
étages
même ? C'est c'est l'industrialisation
de du port. C'est le
les conditions d'élevage, l'industriel,
il s'en préoccupe ou pas du tout ? Du
moment que lui il a sa protéine à tel
tarif, il nen a rien à faire des
conditions
le chinois, il est pas forcément informé
de tout ça. Il est il se renseigne pas
trop. Ce que ce que lui veut surtout
c'est de la sécurité, la sécurité
sanitaire, c'est-à-dire pas être
empoisonné, pas être malade
comme nous. Non,
un peu comme nous. Mais nous, on a quand
même l'image du terroir, de bien
rémunérer le producteur. On n'accepte
pas les fermes de grande échelle. On a
beaucoup, tu sais, on critiqué à une
époque la ferme de 1000 vaches, mais en
Chine, la plus grosse ferme, elle en
fait 100000. C'est la ferme alors le nom
est difficile à dire, je crois, c'est
Shijo Yang. Donc dans la c'est la ferme
de Shijuajang dans la ville de Shijua
Yangang. Donc cette filme, cette ferme,
elle fait 100000 vaches. Donc c'est
c'est vraiment un truc énorme. Euh des
fermes de on a des fermes de 45000
vaches aux États-Unis comme la la H
Farm, on a des enfin voilà des fermes de
plusieurs milliers de vaches. C'est
c'est c'est assez assez commun. Et
ensuite en Chine, alors les les
maintenant la grande mode, oui, c'est de
faire des usines à viande, des usines à
port. En fait, c'est ça ressemble à un
HLM. Ça permet de produire beaucoup.
Ça ressemble à un HLM.
Oui. Non, mais c'est vrai, ça ressemble
à à une barre d'immeuble. Voilà.
Voilà.
Voilà. Ah oui, c'est un abus de langage
mais il y a pas de notion patif dans ma
dans ma bouche. Donc
une cage à lapin, c'est ça ?
Cage à cochon.
Une cage à cochon.
Voilà. Et effectivement, alors j'en
discutais avec un chinois qui me disait
voilà donc notre dernière installation,
il va y avoir 84000 truits qui vont
produire chaque année x porcela. Alors
je sais plus c'est 18 ou 36 et on va
faire je croision de porcela par an.
voilà dans une usine et il me disait que
son usine euh et son groupe alors je
voilà son groupe devrait produire autant
de ports que le Danemark qui est un des
prix les plus gros producteurs de ports
euh au monde.
Mais dans leur logique à eux ils sont
1liard 400000 je crois leur cheptel a
été dévasté par le l'AFS le l'African
Swine Fever donc la la fièvre la fièvre
porsine africaine. Ils ont perdu 50 % du
CHPTEL en arriè
ils considèrent que ce genre
d'installation, ils peuvent la
sécuriser, ils peuvent empêcher le virus
d'entrer. Donc c'est une usine, il y a
rien qui fait rêver. Les cochons, ils
voient jamais la lumière du jour, ils
sont jamais sur le sol, ils sont
toujours dans des cages en béton et
cetera et cetera. Donc c'est c'est
vraiment le pire de la maltraitance
animale, mais c'est sécurisé et en terme
de rendement, c'est-à-dire de de ce
qu'on appelle le feed conversion show,
donc le
le le comment on appelle ça ? le ratio
de conversion alimentaire,
c'est ce qu'il y a de meilleur.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, vous pouvez
faire 1 kg de cochon en consommant
peut-être
3 kg de nourriture, 3,5 de nourriture.
Vous pouvez faire 1 kg de volaille en
consommant 2 k moins de 2 kg de
nourriture.
Donc en terme, voyez quand je dis que
c'est jamais ou tout noir ou tout blanc,
c'estàdire qu'on peut y trouver beaucoup
d'inconvénients et on peut y trouver
aussi quelques avantages.
Question internet. Euh,
vaut-il mieux faut-il faut-il
non, vaut-il mieux acheter au fermier du
nom bio ou acheter en grande surface du
bio ?
La grande surface, elle s'approvisionne
chez les fermiers, j'imagine. Donc, si
vous allez en grande surface et que vous
achetez du bio, bah quelque part, vous
ferez vivre un fermier. Je donc
le fermier local, il peut aussi livrer
le mine, enfin le marché de l'intérêt
national qui va livrer des grossistes,
qui va livrer les grandes surfaces. Euh
moi, j'étais industriel de la salade par
exemple, donc j'achetais à des gros
producteurs, à des gros fermiers euh qui
pouvaient travailler correctement si le
cahier des charges était correct. Donc
au supermarché, on n pas forcément des
mauvais produits. Ça c'est ça que je
veux dire.
Non, il y a dans les super archers, il y
a des bons produits quand même. Moi,
j'ai des bons produits, on peut trouver
du local aussi. Il y a des supermarchés
qui s'approvisionne aussi localement.
J'ai la chance d'avoir le vaisseau
amiral d'une grande marque de
supermarché juste à côté de chez moi.
Ouais,
je peux vous dire c'est une super carte
de visite pour la France. Sauf que bon,
il y a pas un seul touriste dedans. Mais
ouais, mais il peut y avoir de très bons
produits, bien sûr.
Ah, il y a des produits extraordinaires
sur le pinard. Sur le pinard, je sais
pas comment ils font mais ils ont
Oui. sur le pinard, sur le fromage, il y
a plein il y a plein de produits comme
ça. De la viande. Oui, on peut
limite limite de meilleure qualité que
le le boucher du coin.
Oui. Mais quand je compare par exemple
les supermarchés français ou
supermarchés autrichiens ou allemands,
la bouffe, la nourriture en France est
quand même globalement de bien meilleure
qualité. Donc en France, on n pas encore
on a encore quelque part de la chance et
on peut trouver des bons produits si on
le souhaite. En Autriche et en
Allemagne, c'est plus difficile.
L'effort à fournir est plus important.
Question internet. En terme de
consommation mondiale, pouvons-nous dire
que nous sommes trop nombreux ou plutôt
que nous ne savons pas produire de
manière appropriée ? Aujourd'hui, on
produit suffisamment pour tout le monde,
hein. Bah,
il faut dire ça en Afrique, hein.
On produit suffisamment pour tout le
monde. C'est pas pour ça que tout le
monde a ce qu'il lui faut. Donc c'est
c'est mal réparti. Aujourd'hui, on
estime de mémoire les derniers chiffres,
faudrait voir les derniers chiffres de
de l'OMS, mais je crois qu'il y a à peu
près 800 millions de personnes qui
mangent pas correctement, qui sont pas
ce qu'ils appellent en situation de
sécurité alimentaire, qui n'ont pas la
sécurité alimentaire, à peu près 800
millions de personnes et ça va
probablement augmenter avec la crise
actuelle.
Mais des personnes qui mangent trop, on
doit être à 1 milliard et demi ou 2
milliards. Donc il y a d'un côté des
gens qui mangent beaucoup trop en terme
de calories, souvent mal, très mal. Et
puis vous avez effectivement 800
millions de personnes qui mangent mal et
vous avez aujourd'hui peut-être alors ça
dépend des estimations, ça dépend des
études, mais on estime que jusqu'à
un/art de la production est perdue. Donc
il y a un gaspillage phénoménal. Donc
aujourd'hui, on ne manque pas de
surface, on manque pas de quantité, mais
c'est mal distribué et il y a beaucoup
de gens qui malheureusement peuvent pas
se se payer la nourriture disponible.
Question internet. Avec le nombre
croissant de suicide chez les
agriculteurs, les les industriels
doivent-ils prendre leur part de
responsabilité entre parenthèses en plus
de la politique ?
C'est un problème compliqué. Oui,
certainement. Certainement.
Certainement. Après, quel est le juste
prix ? combien il faudrait payer
réellement pour que le producteur soit
bien rémunéré. Alors, on parle beaucoup
de la marque C'est qui le patron qui qui
donne un peu plus d'argent au
producteur. Donc à voir, oui,
probablement que les industriels ont une
responsabilité partager avec les
pouvoirs publics, partagé avec les
distributeurs, partager avec aussi avec
les consommateurs qui qui beaucoup
cherchent les bas prix. Absolument. Le
prix reste quand même le premier critère
d'achat aujourd'hui quand on interroge
les consommateurs. Quel est quels sont
vos critères d'achat ? le prix ça reste
le numéro 1. Donc si on ne veut pas
payer ou si beaucoup de gens ne veulent
pas payer, est-ce que le premier
responsable c'est pas au départ le
consommateur ? Donc oui, c'est une
responsabilité de l'industriel mais
c'est une responsabilité partagée. Donc
voilà et aujourd'hui on n jamais aussi
peu payé pour son alimentation.
C'est c'est vrai.
Voilà.
Question internet son avis ou on a
jamais bon pas c'est un commentaire
personnel qu'on on va s'en passer. son
avis sur les coopératives et sur la
décroissance.
Alors, les coopératives, alors il y a
coopérative et coopérative ça il faut
faire très attention. Euh
je suis très amis avec les fondateurs
d'une coopérative que j'adore. Alors ça
c'est une initiative belge en plus mais
voilà qui s'appelle paysan- artisan. Ils
ont un site internet, ils sont c'est des
gens super, c'est des gens motivés. Euh
et je pense que des initiatives comme ça
devraient être multipliées partout en
Belgique, en France, enfin partout. Euh
ils soutiennent les producteurs, ils
transformment, ils distribuent et en
plus de ça, il y a une vie associative.
Donc ils invitent des gens intéressants
à faire des conférences. Ça a été mon
cas, c'est comme ça que je les ai connu.
Et ils font des projections, ils font
des débats, ils mettent des produits en
avant, ils soutiennent des producteurs.
Il y a du lien social, il y a de la
réflexion, il y a de l'intelligence, il
y a du partage, il y a de la solidarité.
Donc euh ce type de coopérative. Oui,
1000 fois. Oui.
Je vais te demander de lire ça et
ensuite de me lire une page dedans.
Me dis pas que tu as pas tes lunettes,
hein.
Bah c'est ce que j'allais dire. Ben je
vais essayer
donc de te lire ça.
Ah on sent la vieillerie quand même
hein.
Ah oui non mais c'est sûr hein. Même
même si je fais attention à ce que je
mange ça voilà ça se dégrade malgré tout
hein. Alors malgré l'évolution des
mentalités et de certaines législations,
la bataille contre la malbouffe n'est
pas gagnée. Euh 7 ans après son
bestellaire. Vous êtes fou d'avaler ça.
Excellent livre que je recommande.
Christophe Bruxet propose son enquête la
plus aboutie et dénonce preuve à la
pluie. Ça c'est important. Euh et avec
sa verve l'inidieuse contre-attaque de
l'industrie de la malbouffe, lobbyisme
forcé, contournement des règlements,
intimidation des lanceurs d'alerte,
harcèlement judiciaire. Les champions de
la junk food continuent de défendre sans
scrupule leur modèle économique dès les
terre. Trop de produits de leader de
l'industrie agroalimentaire sont nocifs
pour la santé. Ultra transformé, trop
sucré et ou trop salé, contaminé par des
polluants ou des molécules toxiques
ajoutées, déséquilibrées et vites de
nutriments. Tu veux que je continue ? Tu
ouvres le bouquin.
Quelle page ?
Et tu choisis, tu le fais au hasard.
Alors, au hasard. Pouf !
Vas-y, dis-moi juste un passage.
C'est écrit au petit.
Alors, ça commence un peu de manière
abrupte he et je mets et les paysans ne
sont pas les seuls à avoir été trahis.
après 9 mois de débat parlementaire, le
Conseil constitutionnel, alors là je
parle de site de mémoire de la loi
égalim
euh donc de 2018 si je me souviens bien
où en fait on avait eu un certain nombre
d'articles et le conseil constitutionnel
donc constitué de neuf membres nonus a
censuré un/art des articles, notamment
certains concernant la protection de
l'environnement ou l'étiquetage de
l'origine du miel. Donc je parle de ça
parce que le miel c'est un sujet qui me
que je connais bien et sur lequel je
suis très sensible. Est-ce que ce
bouquin, il a été relu par un avocat, un
juriste, un éditeur ou
là ? beaucoup plus que ça. Alors,
sachant vu les lettres de menace
d'avocat que je reçois, les coups de fil
incendiaires, les communiqués, je
m'autocensure. J'essaie de pas le faire
mais malheureusement
malheureusement je le fais parce que de
toute façon, je sais que mon auditeur le
fera ensuite. Pour ce livre-là, pas cher
en dans toutes les bonnes crémeries, euh
je me suis autocensuré, je dois
l'avouer. Mon ép mon épouse, pardon, m'a
relu après, parce qu'elle m'a dit "Je te
fais pas confiance, tu parles trop. Donc
elle m'a relu, elle m'a recensuré. Euh
mon éditeur m'a censuré parce qu'il m'a
dit "Ça tu peux pas le dire, ça tu peux
pas, ça". Et ensuite on l'a fait lire un
avocat spécialisé pour être pour
vraiment blindé. Et à malgré ces trois
relectures et ces censures successives,
on a encore eu dû faire 75
modifications. 75 sur un livre de 200
pages, de 300 pages.
Donc donc voilà, c'est c'est c'est le
genre de chose qui me met hors de moi
quoi. On peut plus rien même les choses
vraies. le dénigrement. Alors quand même
pour parler du dénigrement, c'est que
bou
on parle du dénigrement mais on donne
pas de
Ah non non, on donne pas mais juste pour
dans le principe, le dénigrement c'est
un dévoiement d'une loi qui doit
protéger les industriels contre la
concurrence des loyales. Donc c'est dans
le code du commerce. vous êtes un
commerçant ou un industriel, vous pouvez
pas dénigrer votre concurrent en disant
par exemple mon produit à moi, il est
meilleur que le sien, le sien c'est
merdique. Donc ça, on n pas le droit et
ça se comprend. Par contre, les
industriels ont trouvé malin de de
d'utiliser cette loi contre les lanceurs
d'alerte ou contre les associations, les
ONG et cetera en disant voilà, ces
gens-là n'ont pas le droit de dire du
mal de mon produit et ils n'ont pas le
droit même si c'est vrai. C'est ça qui
est fou. Même si c'est vrai, je peux pas
dire qu'un produit est merdique. C'est
pas possible. On peut m'attaquer pour
dénigrement et je peux être condamné
pour ça. La dernière
et si je te laisse le faire, je peux
être aussi attaqué.
Oui, mais moi je fais et en plus en plus
ce qui est fou, c'est que j'ai pas
l'intention de dénigrer. Je veux
dénigrer personne. C'est pas productif.
C'est c'est dénigrer, c'est idiot. Ça
sert à rien. Ça apporte rien au débat.
Donc je dénigre pas par principe. Et en
plus, moi j'ai beaucoup de d'affection
pour les industriels. Je sais d'où je
viens. Je m'en rappelle. Je sais que
souvent on fait des enfin mes collègues
font des choses et ils sont malheureus
malheureux de les faire. Donc j'ai
voilà, j'ai aucune envie de dénigré,
c'est pas du tout mon but. Mais la
dernière fois, le dernier courrier
d'avocat que j'ai reçu, c'était pour des
tests sur des épices. J'ai parfaitement
vu que les épices que j'ai testé
beaucoup étaient fraodées juste en les
voyant, en les goûtant par rapport à
l'espace. J'ai 10 ans d'espace dans les
épices. Donc je sais reconnaître une
épice qui je je sais
qui est bizarre
qui est bizarre. Voilà, quand je la
vois, voilà, il y a des indices qui me
permettent de dire "Cette épice est
bizarre." Et en plus, les toutes les
épices que j'avais regardé ont été
testées et analysé scientifiquement pour
vérifier ce que je pouvais dire. Et le
le la personne qui les a analysé, qui
est un expert judiciaire avec les
machines qui vont bien, avec l'expertise
qui va bien, m'a dit, "Bon, je l'ai
appelé après, je dis bon voilà, les
pistes que j'ai testé, j'ai reçu un
courrier d'avocat, qu'est-ce que tu peux
m'en dire ?" Je le savais même pas. Il
m'a dit "Bah voilà, je t'envoie le
rapport." Il m'a dit, il m'a dit "Oui,
elle est pas clean. Elle est pas clean."
Il m'a pas dit elle est fraudée. Il m'a
dit "C'est pas à moi de le dire, c'est
au juge. Je peux pas dire qu'elle est
fraudée mais elle est pas clean." Et
elle m'a dit "Voilà, il y a ce qui va
voilà ça qui va pas, ça qui va pas, ça
qui va pas." Et ce que j'avais dit dans
mon dans ma dans mon expertise, dans mon
dans mon évaluation visuelle et
organoleque, il me l'a confirmé par ses
analyses.
Question internet. Que pensez-vous des
algues entre parenthèses ou plutôt le
légume de la mer
pour nourrir les hommes et les bêtes ?
Bah les algues, on en fait beaucoup en
Bretagne, on en a même plus qu'on en
voudrait. Donc couchons aussi en
Bretagne non
on en fait beaucoup, on en fait même la
moitié du chapitel français est en
Bretagne. 7 % du territoire à 50 % des
ports français. Donc c'est pour ça que
ça pose problème. Donc ce que je pense
des algouill c'est des oui c'est des
bons produits. C'est un voilà c'est un
végétal. C'est bon pour les végage.
C'est c'est riche enode. C'est plein de
bons de bons produits. Donc oui les
végan c'est bien. Euh ensuite en Asie
donc moi, j'ai passé beaucoup de temps.
Les algues là-bas sont très populaires
hein. En snack, on a souvent des algues.
Donc voilà, les Japonais en consomment
énormément. Donc oui, c'est un bon
produit. Oui. Oui. La l'étude mer, ce
genre de choses, les Ulves sont des bons
produits.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous ?
Il y en a énormément.
Alors Justin,
Justin Justin je sais pas. On parlait de
la Bretagne, on parlait des lanceurs
d'alerte, on parlait des menaces, on
parlait de mon ami Yasmine, on parlait
on pourrait parler d'Ines Lero aussi, on
enfin il y a tellement de sujets
intéressants des lanceurs d'alerte, on
pourrait euh la démocratie, la liberté,
ça c'est intéressant aussi. C'est en
lien avec ça justement. C'est un sujet
ou ça on pourrait en parler
effectivement qu'en France, moi je je
m'inquiète beaucoup tu vois. Je je
pensais pas que en France je dois me
censurer au point où je me censure
aujourd'hui. Je pensais que dans
l'intérêt du public, on pourrait dire
des choses.
Si tu censurais pas, il y aurait une
révolution.
Oui, mais je pense que des choses
pourraient être dites. Quand je vois
comment sont traités les gilets jaunes,
ça morifie. quand je vois que voilà
qu'on trouve pas de moyen pour les pour
sécuriser certains quartiers pour le
l'hôpital pour la sécurité publique pour
les les contrôles, la DGCRF et cetera,
mais que quand il y a des gilets jaunes,
il y a il y a plus de policiers que de
gilets jaunes, je me pose beaucoup de
questions quand même. Donc quand le
pouvoir est menacé, il sait se protéger.
Quand l'industrie est menacée, on sait
la protéger. Euh mais l'intérêt des
citoyens, non, c'est non. Quand les gens
veulent participer à la démocratie,
c'est suspect. Ça pose problème.
Euh donc voilà, on est voilà,
apparemment en tant que citoyen, on est
juste bon à à à désigner son son maître
parmi un choix très restreint
ou son bourreau.
Oui. Ou son bourreau. Enfin bon, voilà.
Donc on et c'est pour ça que ben
malheureusement la plupart des gens
aujourd'hui ils y croient plus quoi. Ils
y croient plus parce qu'ils se rendent
bien compte que ça sert pas à
grand-chose.
Et c'est ça qui est triste. Et d'un côté
c'est triste mais d'un autre côté quand
j'en parle à Maxime Maxime Ren que tu
connais bah ça le met en colère et puis
il se dit "Ouais, il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose et on appellera un tel et
on fera ça et puis je connais un
collectif et puis voilà et et
heureusement il y a des gens comme ça
qui se qui se bougent les fesses.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Oui.
Oui. Euh alors justement, j'ai lu
beaucoup de bouquins pour préparer
celui-là. Euh donc, on a parlé donc de
Nasche, donc Nasche, la maladie de la
malbouffe, euh du docteur Dominique Lan,
euh qui un livre super facile à lire,
extrêmement intéressant, euh quelqu'un
qui connaît son sujet, qui sait de quoi
il parle, qui est qui est très
intéressant. C'est pas du tout un livre
rébarbatif, donc vraiment je le
conseille. Il se lit très bien, très
facilement. Il a plein d'anecdotes,
plein d'exemples. Donc vraiment un très
très bon livre.
Euh, un autre livre que j'ai beaucoup
aimé, alors il s'appelle Cochonnerie au
pluriel.
C'est bon la cochonnerie, non ?
Oui. Oui. C'est pas forcément ce que tu
penses. Donc c'est cochonnerie. Alors,
le sous-titre c'est euh cochonnerie.
Comment comment la les charcuterie ou la
charcuterie est devenue un poison ? Donc
il raconte que en fait
pas toute la charcuterie,
c'est le titre. Donc là, c'est je il y a
pas des c'est le sous-titre. C'est
comment là où les charcuteries sont
devenus un poison. et il explique
comment bah en fait avant les années 60
les nitrates nitrites n'étaient pas
autorisés dans les charcouteries. Donc
on nous dit aujourd'hui on veut nous
faire croire que les nitrate nitrite
c'est utilisé depuis la l'Égypte antique
que on sans faire sans nitrate nitrite
on peut pas faire de charcuterie.
Donc il nous explique que c'est
complètement faux. Il nous explique que
le le jambon de parme par exemple depuis
depuis des dizaines d'années, il est
fait sans nitrate et nitrite. Donc voilà
la charcuterie on peut parfaitement en
faire sans sans additif. Donc voilà.
Alors, l'auteur c'est Guillaume.
Guillaume, je sais pas si c'est pas
Guillaume Coudret euh mais je là il
faudrait vérifier. Enfin voilà. Euh
pareil, c'est facile à lire, peut-être
moins facile que le premier mais enfin
bon pareil très argumenté, très voilà.
Euh un livre, une BD. Alors c'est c'est
là c'est pareil, c'est super facile à
lire. C'est de Dines Lero, donc c'est sa
fameuse histoire sur les algues vertes.
Donc c'est c'est un pareil, c'est un
succès de librairie, mais il y a il y a
une vraie problématique derrière. C'est
sourcé, c'est intéressant, ça se lit
facilement parce que c'est une BD. Euh
donc voilà. Donc ça s'appelle alors les
algues vertes, je crois c'est l'enquête
interdite si je me trompe pas.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà. Dinler. Donc pareil, ça c'est un
livre que j'ai dévoré.
Voilà, c'est vraiment les trois livres
qui m'ont marqué parmi la vingtaine que
j'ai lu pour l'enquête.
Guillaume Coudret, comment le
charcuterie est devenu un poison.
Voilà, c'est un livre peut-être ancien
mais qui a pas perdu de sa pertinence.
Juste une question sur le développement
durable.
Développement durable. Développement
durable. Oui. Bah c'est un impératif de
toute façon. Il faudra qu'on y arrive.
Ça l'industrie par contre s'est emparé
du problème. Bah contrainte est forcé
aussi he parce que les réglementations,
tu vois quand les réglementations sont
bien faites et qu' qu'elles incitent à
ce moment-là. Donc ça se met ça se met
en ça se met en œuvre. Donc les
industriels aujourd'hui font leur bilan
carbone, regardent ce qu'ils consomment,
on regarde les transports qui peuvent
être les moins polluants, le le
maritime. On essaie de voir si on peut
trouver des sources plus proches,
essayer de relocaliser certaines
productions pour la sécurité et pour le
bilan carbone. Donc les industriels
travaillent beaucoup là-dessus. On sait
aussi que ça va être une contrainte de
plus en plus législative, de plus en
plus importante. Donc on s'y prépare.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable ? Euh
alors là, ça par contre, j'y ai pas
réfléchi. Euh ben écoute, moi je je
pense qu'il faut écouter écouter ses
rêves et puis essayer de les réaliser
quoi parce qu'on a qu'une vie, elle est
relativement courte et plus je veillis,
plus j'approche de l'échéan et plus je
me dis qu'effectivement il faut pas
s'embêter quoi.
Je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas sœur du rêve.
Oui. Et puis il faut pas hésiter à
prendre des risques et que voilà. Donc
là, il y a des gens qui ont beaucoup
souffert. Je pense à Yasmine justement.
Yasmine Motard Gémie, elle a eu 10 ans
de procédure, elle a dépensé des
centaines de milliers d'euros en
procédure, elle a été vraiment
calomniée, bâchée et cetera.
Malheureusement pour elle, ça a été un
des premiers lanceurs d'alerte, hein.
Donc toujours les premiers les premiers
qui s'exposent sont les ce sont ceux qui
s'en prennent plein la gueule. Euh
pareil pour pour comment elle s'appelle
? pour Stéphanie Gibao, elle a été
on lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs, on
le
voilà, elle pareil, elle s'en est pris
plein les dents. Donc donc je l'ai
contacté, je enfin avec avec Alexandre,
on lui a assuré notre soutien. On essayé
de voir avec elle comment on pouvait
l'aider, la soutenir. Voilà. Enfin, on
essaie vraiment de se fédérer entre nous
parce que alors une chose, j'ai écrit au
défenseurs des droits pour alors
soit-disant enfin, on nous dit que tout
est fait aujourd'hui pour défendre les
lanceurs d'alerte. Il y a même des voilà
donc il y a toute une communication, il
y a les syndicats des ONG qui font
l'hôtel des lanceurs d'alerte, le le le
refuge des lance, enfin je sais plus
trop quoi. Enfin bref, ces gens-là, je
les ai jamais vu, j'ai jamais entendu
parler. Euh euh le soi-disant, il y a
une loi pour protéger les lanceurs
d'alerte. Alors aujourd'hui, il y a une
seule personne et c'est Stéphanie Gibau
qui a été reconnu officiellement comme
lanceur d'alerte. Moi, je me suis amusé
à écrire au défenseur des droits en
disant voilà, j'aimerais bien être
reconnu comme lanceur d'alerte. On m'a
répondu au bout de je sais plus combien
de semaines en me disant bah voilà, il
faut le prouver. Prouve-le en fonction
des articles 6 12 42 de la du code de je
sais pas quoi que machin. Envoie-nous
les preuves comme quoi tu es vraiment un
lanceur d'alerte que tu as bien respecté
les procédures
sous un mois
sous un mois sinon ton dossier sera
passé à la déchieteuse.
Donc voilà, ça m'a bien enf c'est une
réponse à laquelle je m'attendais mais
ça m'a bien fait comprendre et ça m'a
oui confirmé que et ce qu'on pense tous
c'est-à-dire ce que ce que voilà les
quelques personnes avec qui j'en ai
parlé avec qui on échange que oui, il y
a une une grosse propagande en faisant
croire qu'on défend les lanceurs
d'alerte mais en fait non on les on les
laisse se faire massacrer. Et le cas de
Stéphanie est intéressant puisque elle a
été reconnue officiellement par le
défenseur des droits comme une lanceuse
d'alerte. C'est la première elle
lanceuse non
une lanceuse oui tout à fait. Comme une
lanceuse d'alerte. C'est la première. Et
malgré tout euh le ministère des
finances qui quand même quand même
récupéré 5 milliards grâce à elle, au
moins 5 milliards d'euros grâce à elle,
refuse de l'indemniser, est prêt à aller
en procédure et refuse de lui filer le
moindre copec.
C'est pour ça que Bruno Lemè veut pas
venir nous voir.
Je sais pas, je crois.
On risquerait de lui poser trop de
questions.
Ouais, il y aurait il y aurait
effectivement des choses à dire.
Euh je suis désolé, je vais quand même
t'en poser une dernière qui vient
d'Internet. Ne regarde pas ta montre,
s'il te plaît. Quel ratio calories Quel
ratio calories énergétique consommé sur
calories alimentaires produites pour le
bio, le conventionnel, l'agroécologique
?
Oh là là, j'ai déjà du mal à comprendre
la question. Quel ratio calories
consommé par quel rapport à calor
produit ?
Alors, quel ratio calories ? Alors, je
vais la retransformer pour la la rendre
plus bitable.
Ouais, mais je comprends. C'est en gros
c'est ce qu'on r non quel ratio de
calories fossiles.
Ouais. pour la calorie euh assimilée,
pour le bio, le conventionnel de
l'agroécologie. C'est peut-être pas ça
l'essence de la question.
Ouais, mais je comprends. C'est en gros
c'est euh est-ce que c'est plus polluant
de produire conventionnel, de produire
bio, de produire agroécologie ? Voilà,
c'est [grognement] vrai que les les
modes de production qui sont à plus
forte productivité, je pense par exemple
à la permaculture, c'est y a des petites
surfaces avec beaucoup de main d'œuvre
et cetera ont une bonne productivité et
je pense un meilleur bilan carbone.
Alors, je suis pas un expert de ces
productions là. Il faudrait voir. Après,
ça dépend aussi des types de production,
ça dépend donc du produit, du climat, du
sol, il faudrait voir. Et il faut aussi
bien qu'on prenne en compte l'ensemble,
tu vois. par exemple pour pour produire
des engrais chimiques.
Donc il pour prendre en compte le vrai
impact carbone du conventionnel, il faut
il faut remonter toute la chaîne.
C'estàd combien ça coûte de carbone pour
produire de l'engrais chimique, combien
ça coûte de carbone pour faire des
pesticides. Euh il faut voir aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on importe, qu'est-ce qu'on
exporte. Tu vois, tu parlais du du setup
par exemple, des moi enfin je comprends
pas ce genre de Non, pour moi c'est il y
a aucun intérêt dans ces trucs. Le tout
premier achat que j'ai fait dans ma
carrière d'acheteur, c'est d'acheter un
container de haricot rouge du Canada.
C'est le premier achat que j'ai fait.
C'était en 94 95, je sais plus.
Et tu t'en rappelles comme si c'était
hier ?
Oui oui oui oui oui ouai. Je me rappelle
parce que c'était un métier qui moi je
voulais être acheteur, ça me faisait
rêver. Donc et je me rappelle le gars
m'avait dit "Tu parles couramment
anglais ?" Bien sûr.
For sure my friend. Alors, j'y avais dit
bah bien sûr, bien sûr, bien sûr. Et
j'avais comme tout étudiant à l'époque
un niveau en anglais déplorable.
Et bah, il m'a dit "Bah c'est bien bah
je te laisse négocier avec le canadien."
Et il m'a passé le téléphone et c'est à
ce moment-là que c'est joué mon futur
quoi.
Il était québécois ?
Non, non, il était il était euh du
Manitoba, je crois et et il parlait.
Ils sont sympas dans le Manitoba.
Ouais. Oui. Ou non, ils sont les
Canadiens sont super sympas. Très très
sympa. Non non, j'ai très bons potes
là-bas. Donc, ils sont très très sympas.
Et euh et ce que je veux dire c'est que
le fait qu'il y ait pas de CTA ne m'a
jamais empêché d'acheter de au Canada de
la lentille. C'est le plus gros
producteur mondial de lentille. C'est le
plus gros producteur mondial de de
légumineuse, de poids, de haricot. Il y
a J'ai jamais eu aucun problème pour
acheter du Canada. Enfin, je je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait besoin d'un accord
supplémentaire. Euh ensuite, ce qui est
ce qui est drôle, c'est enfin ce qui est
drôle, toujours pareil, c'est pas le bon
terme, mais ce qui est surprenant, c'est
que ça coûte beaucoup moins cher euh
d'acheter un produit au Canada comme de
la lentille et de la faire livrer en
France que d'acheter de la lentille
française en France.
elle coûtera moins cher parce que au
Canada, ils ont des grandes surfaces, il
y a de la chimie, ils ont beaucoup moins
de normellement
je suis extrêmement hostile à ces
accords. Pour moi, le le le producteur
français a tout à perdre.
Christophe Bruxellet, merci.
Merci à vous. Merci beaucoup.
[musique]